Das war was ganz einfaches. Es ist noch Alexander, ein Sequenzenförderung und dann war das......ne, war nicht forschend. Es war irgendwas......ich würde sagen Festnetz...
Hast du das jetzt auch mit Java gehackt, den ganzen Kram?
Die statische HTML ist halt ein Scala geschrieben. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, aber das ist auch so eine JVM-Sprache, aber funktional objektorientiert.
Eine Multiparadigmen-Sprache, ist das doch?
Es ist halt überleben im Java-Land, ist Scala. Da hast du noch genug Nestwärme mit dem ganzen restigen Java-Kram.
Aber den benutzt man ja immer weniger. Ich bin ja klassisch umgestiegen und je länger ich Scala probiere, desto weniger wird. Da passt übrigens eins der Themen rein, die ich aufgeschrieben hab. RoboVM.
Jetzt gleich?
Aber können wir auch später drüber reden. Schon von gehört? Eine schwedische Firma war der Meinung, sie müssten jetzt mal endlich Java aufs iPhone bringen. Und haben ein LLVM-Frontend gebaut, was Java nach nativen Code kompiliert. Das Ganze angewürzt mit einem Garbage-Collector und ein paar Bridge-Classes, damit das auch mit Objective-C-Runtime funktioniert. Das Ganze nennt sich dann RoboVM.
Ist das das, was jetzt auch Google verwendet für seine Apps?
Keine Ahnung, aber es wurde wohl auf der Google IO oder irgendeine Google-Dinginstar-Konferenz wurde das groß gehypt. Ich hab da mal reingeguckt. Also technisch ist es auf jeden Fall mal sehr spannend, dass jemand also irgendwie tatsächlich versucht, also überhaupt erstmal Java in nativen Code zu kompilieren. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das schon mal vorher jemand versucht hat. Und das dann aber auch noch irgendwie mit Objective-C-Runtime, die ja irgendwie kein Garbage-Collector, sondern einen ARC verwendet zu verheiraten, finde ich einfach mal total super. Also mit Java 8 lambdas in Objective-C-Blocks umbauen und so weiter. Also die Jungs, die sind echt hart drauf. Ich weiß allerdings nicht, wie gut es funktioniert. Aber man kann das mal im Hinterkopf behalten.
Ah, jetzt weiß ich, was ich meinte. Ich meinte J2Objective-C. Hätten Sie es nicht irgendwie Synergy nennen können? Nein, also J2Objective-C. A Java to iOS Objective-C translation tool in runtime. Das scheint mir jetzt sowas Ähnliches zu sein.
Kann das sein? Kann sein. Hab ich noch nicht von gehört. Ich hab mich bei diesem RoboVM auch mal so ein bisschen durch das GitHub-Zeug geklickt. Also es ist alles irgendwie open source. Aber ich nix Java, insofern kann ich da auch nicht so genau was zu sagen. Aber ich fand das auf jeden Fall mal interessant, dass jemand sowas echt versucht. Und relativ viele Spiele werden da wohl irgendwie aufs iPhone portiert, weil, keine Ahnung, es gibt wohl viele Leute, die schreiben Spiele in Java.
Dieses Google Code ist auch halt so tot, ne? Also alle haben da oben ihren roten Link. Wir sind jetzt auf GitHub, haben es alle eingesehen.
Sogar die von Google, die Projekte.
Wir sind jetzt auf SourceForge, äh, nein.
Ja, ich freu mich, wie sich das jetzt zueinander verhält, hier deine RoboVM. Was ist das RoboVM Org?
Nee, Org glaub ich nicht. Oder? Also, wie gesagt, ich hab's nicht ausprobiert.
Das ist hier so mit irgendwie kostet Geld und das andere ist Open Source.
Also der Hintergrund ist wohl, dass da so eine schwedische Firma irgendwelche Software aufs iPhone portieren wollte und statt die neu zu schreiben, haben sie halt das gemacht.
Es gibt ja hier auch dieses App Portable, was dir dabei eben das umgekehrt macht, dass du deinen Coco-Kram auf Android laufen lassen kannst. Da ist schon ordentlich Kohle drin. Also ich meine, hier zum Beispiel bei uns, wir wollen ja auch unsere Spiele da, unsere Schlumpfbeeren-Spielchen, immer auf beiden Plattformen haben und es natürlich dann auch immer ungeil, zwei Entwicklungsteams zu haben. Und dann hängst du mit dem einen immer so ein bisschen hinterher oder so und wäre schon natürlich toll, eine Codebase für alle Plattformen zu haben. Aber ich glaube, ich halte das ja für eine ähnliche Illusion wie das CMS, was alle Anforderungen von allen Leuten erfüllt.
Ja, aber ein GUI für alle OS-er, das sieht aber scheiße aus.
Na gut, bei Spielen ist das mit der GUI jetzt nicht so wild.
Ich meinte ja auch nur als Vergleich. Weil die haben dann alle wieder eine gemeinsame Codebase, aber die ist ja relativ klein, weil keiner kann irgendwie Special Features von irgendeiner Plattform ausnutzen. Und hast halt auch als Plattform kein Alleinstellungsmerkmal, deswegen finden die Firmen das eigentlich auch scheiße, wenn die kleinen Buden sowas machen. Also Google mögen das eigentlich nicht.
Was ich interessant fand, ich hab mir das halt so ein bisschen angeguckt, die benutzen diesen Böhm Garbage Collector. Und das ist irgendwie so Standard in der C++-Welt. Aber wenn man sich dann mal so durchliest, was der so macht, dann klingt der extrem nach dem, was Apple versucht hat, irgendwie mit ihrem Garbage Collector, was sie ja dann letzten Endes aufgegeben haben. Und fürs iPhone haben sie halt dann arg gemacht. Und das wahrscheinlich aus gutem Grund. Insofern kann ich, ich kann's mir einfach nicht vorstellen, dass du da nicht in massive Probleme reinläufst, was Speicher und Formats anbelangt.
Aber ist nicht Garbage Collection auch ein bisschen irgendwie letztes Jahr 1000, nachdem das jetzt so argmäßig gemacht wird?
Das ist deine Meinung, das ist meine Meinung, aber es gibt offensichtlich Leute da draußen, die finden es noch ganz cool.
Die haben die Sonne noch nicht gesehen.
Tja, nicht jedem scheint sie aus dem Arsch.
Oder gibt es noch einen validen Grund, warum ein Garbage-Collector Vorteile hat?
Ja, weil wenn irgendwie die Sprache taugt, dann kann das halt auch gut funktionieren. So ein Garbage-Collector muss sich halt überhaupt nicht um diesen Scheißdreck kümmern.
Also wenn die Sprache taugt und du hast einen dicken Rechner mit 32 Gigrem, ist das alles Schnafte?
Ne eben nicht, weil die scheiß Garbage Collection dann genau dem Ding zuschlägt, wo du gerade deine Millisekunden voll dringt hast, weil du gerade GUI-Updates machst, und dann schlägt der Garbage Collection dazu und dann ruckelt alles unter Scheiße.
Ja, die Diskussion kann man ewig führen. Also der Punkt ist, naja, ist doch so. Der Punkt ist, Apple hat sich dagegen entschieden und ist der Meinung, da gute Gründe zu haben. Und dass sie es jetzt in Swift auch nicht eingebaut haben, sondern Swift auch arg benutzt, sagt ja, dass sie sich ihre Meinung nicht geändert haben. Interessant finde ich ja, dass LLVM intern diesen Böhm Garbage Collection benutzt. Also irgendwie die Leute, die LLVM machen, die benutzen diesen Garbage Collector und sie wissen, was sie tun und trotzdem benutzen sie ihn nicht in den Sprachen, die sie damit programmieren.
Intern, was jetzt in LLVM, dem Compiler?
Im Code selbst jetzt meinste. Also die Garbage Collection sich selbst mit dem Böhm.
Das ist halt keine Realtime-Anforderung, aber du willst halt einfach eine zuverlässige Garbage Collection haben, damit dir das Ding nicht wegblutet.
Außerdem haben die halt in C++ gekodet, das geht ja dann nun mal auch nicht anders, richtig?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es noch einen anderen gibt, der C++, C, C++ unterschätzt.
Ja, aber der LFVM ist ja eben nicht in Objective-C oder in Swift gekodet so, dass sie dann arg benutzen könnten, sondern sie müssen es ja so machen.
Ich meine nur, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die Jungs, die jetzt halt den LFVM machen, die wissen, was sie tun, weil sie halt auch einen Garbage Collector selber verwenden und wissen, was das für Randbedingungen hat.
Sind denn das alles Jungs?
Metaphorisch gesprochen. Die Damen und Herren.
Meinst du, vielleicht kommt irgendwann der LFVM auch in Swift-gecodet raus? Nee, geht eigentlich nicht, das macht keinen Sinn.
Nein, won't happen. Schauen wir mal, was überhaupt alles irgendwann mal in Swift-gecodet wird. Ich meine, das mag ja jetzt für Apple ein ganz interessanter Weg sein, aber es wird halt wieder eine Sprache sein, die jetzt über die Apple-Plattform hinaus keinerlei Bedeutung erlangen wird.
Gut, Objective-C als zumindest so eine der großen drei inzwischen.
Ja, außerhalb der Apple-Plattform keinerlei Bedeutung.
Ja, und war aber jetzt auch nicht so schlimm.
Ich sage nicht, dass es schlimm ist. Ich sage nur, so ist es. Es gibt ja auch Programmiersprachen, da musst du dir nicht vorher irgendwie festlegen, auf welche Plattform du die benutzen willst. Das finde ich eigentlich auch ganz charmant. Ich meine, man sollte schon auch in seinem Leben mal eine Programmiersprache erlernt haben, die nicht auf ein einziges Betriebssystem festgelegt ist. Finde ich. Muss man nicht so sehen. Ansonsten, wie so ein Garbage-Collector performt, hängt halt mal sehr von der Sprache ab. Das ist extrem davon abhängig. Weil es gibt sehr wohl Sprachen, die sind ideal für Garbage-Collektoren. Und da hast du auch überhaupt gar kein Problem mit Garbage-Collektoren. Sobald ich da so erlangen, ist zum Beispiel so ein Beispiel, weil einfach Funktionen leben nur so kurz überhaupt. Und da ist dann immer so klar, was da abgeräumt werden kann. Und vor allem, wenn du so eine immutable Welt hast, wo sowieso keine Variable verändert, dann ist es so klar, was du da abräumen musst. Und da sind solche Garbage-Collektoren einfach so performant. Da kann die Sprache, da weiß die einfach Bescheid. Die weiß einfach, was nicht benutzt wird. Und das kommt dann einfach weg. Und du musst dir über Speicher einfach keine Gedanken machen.
Wahrscheinlich ist es sowieso eher so ein halbes Arc, was die da benutzen.
Garbage-Collektoren sind vor allem deshalb ein schlechter Ruf, weil sie halt nicht sehr vorhersagbar sind, wie du das schon richtig festgestellt hast. So Realtime, aber es gibt auch durchaus noch so Realtime, Garbage-Collektoren, Konzepte, inwiefern die wirklich gut funktionieren, weiß ich nicht, aber Konzepte gibt es auf jeden Fall noch.
Gut, jetzt darfst du wieder, nachdem ich reingegrätscht habe, wo waren wir?
Womit du so das Geld sprungen hast?
Scala heißt das doch bestimmt.
Scala sagt doch gar kein Mensch. Wir sind hier nicht zum Spaß. Das ist ein Podcast.
Blutiger Ernst.
So, ich kicke jetzt mal, wie es hier aussieht.
Wie sieht das denn aus?
Naja, wir haben hier mal unsere Themenliste ein bisschen bearbeiten.
Mal ein bisschen Schupferlein.
Hier guck mal, Markus, dieser Name ist doch noch gar nicht gefallen hier.
Spiel des Lebens. Ja, das andere Projekt, wo ich so involviert bin, das ist quasi Spiel des Lebens, kennt ihr sicher alle, dieses Brettspiel? Aus den 70ern. Das alte Brettspiel, genau, aus den 70ern. Und das haben wir und zwar die Truppe, die das gemacht hat, ist die Theater Company Prinzip Gonzo. ich suche auch gleich mal einen Link raus.
Ah, das ist doch Spiel des Lebens, das ist doch...
Das ist doch das Brette, ich brauch das Brett.
Das ist das schlechtere Monopoly.
Das kenn ich irgendwie nicht, glaub ich.
Das ist irgendwie kein Brett davon, das ist auf jeden Fall nicht.
Das hat doch so, war das nicht das mit diesem Plastikrad in der Mitte da?
Dein Leben ist langweilig und geht immer nach demselben Konzept. Heiraten muss er. Hier ist es doch, warte mal, da gibt's bestimmt auch ein Scan von diesem scheiß Brett.
Ja, links war schon ein ganz gutes Bild eigentlich. Mit dem Grad fand ich hier das da, der zweite, da.
640 x 418, naja.
Die Hörer raten wieder, was wir hier sehen.
Guck mal, hier schon mit Spongebob und so, das von den Hörern.
Da geht's mit der Geburt los und hört mit dem Tod auf und man muss halt möglichst viel Geld scheffeln in dem Spiel.
Der Frau hat richtig viel Kinder.
Und heiraten muss man.
Aus welchem Land kommt das?
Amerika.
Und wir haben uns halt zusammengetan und haben dieses Spiel als so 3D-Intertheater-Interaktion realisiert. Und zwar haben wir da so eine Fabrikhalle in Oberschöne Weide hier in Berlin, gleich neben dem Lager.
Auch bekannt als Oberschweine Öde.
Oberschweine Öde, genau. Gemietet mit vielen vielen Räumen und haben da dieses Spiel spielen lassen. Vielleicht hat man einen Link in den Chat geworfen. Die ersten 40 Sekunden, das erkläre ich nicht eigentlich ganz gut. Also Spiel des Lebens, es gibt halt so verschiedene Werte.
Sie lieben das Spiel? Sie suchen die Herausforderung? Sie tragen den Homoludens in sich? Prinzip Gonzo präsentiert die einmalige Gelegenheit, eine neue Biografie auszuprobieren. Spiel des Lebens, ein Gesellschaftsspiel im dreidimensionalen Raum. Spielen Sie ein Leben durch, nach Ihren Wünschen, von der Wiege bis zur Barre. 18 Räume, 25 Performerinnen, 1000 mögliche Entscheidungen und der Mann mit der Sense. Wie Sie teilnehmen können.
Ganz einfach.
Gehen Sie auf www.ballhausost.de.
Ich komme ein bisschen älter.
Also Spielbrett ist sozusagen dieser riesengroße Raum, den wir da hatten mit Bühne und da gingen viele einzelne Zimmer ab. In jedem Zimmer gab es sozusagen eine Station, also z.B. die Fabrik, da konnte man arbeiten, um Geld zu verdienen, ein Fitnessstudio, die Bank. Und in jedem Raum gab es einen Performer, also einen Schauspieler. Und als Besucher oder Spieler musste man halt mit denen interagieren. Und es gab, ich hab das auch mal...
Ich hab da mal was vorbereitet.
Ich hab jetzt hier mal so das Handbuch mitgebracht. Das sind so 50 Seiten.
Das Handbuch, für wen? Für die... Totholz, für die Performer.
Für die Performer, genau. Und im Prinzip, man kommt halt rein ins Leben. Man muss sozusagen durch so eine große Vagina, wird man sozusagen ins Leben gespült.
Ist man dann schon nass, oder?
Muss man dann schreien? Vielleicht ein bisschen geordnet mal vorgehen. Es gibt sozusagen drei Werte in dem Spiel. Und zwar Geld, Gesundheit und Karma. Und nach diesen Werten richtet sich sozusagen die Punktenzahl des Spielers oder der Spielerin. Und wir haben also am Anfang, wenn man geboren wird, zieht man einen sogenannten Badge, das ist sozusagen ein QR-Code drauf. Und der identifiziert sozusagen den Spieler eindeutig. Und es werden sozusagen initiale Werte vergeben für Geld, Gesundheit und Karma. Da gibt's fünf Abstufungen, also um auch sozusagen die Bevölkerung zu reflektieren. Also es gibt Leute, die haben halt viel Geld und es gibt halt die Leute, die mit dem Silberlöffel im Mund geboren werden. Und das entscheidet sich sozusagen an der Stelle. Und dann geht's halt los mit der Schule. Dann kommt man in der Schule, dann lernt man ein paar Dinge. Eigentlich wird halt erklärt, wie das Spiel funktioniert. Man hört halt auf mit einer, es wird sozusagen so eine Art Test geschrieben. Der wird benotet. Und dann geht man halt sozusagen in den großen Raum rein. Und ist wie in so einer Open World. Und kann dann eigentlich machen, was man möchte. Und interagiert mit den Schauspielern, mit den anderen Spielern. Man geht studieren, man macht eine Ausbildung. Man wird zum Psychiater geschickt. Wir hatten auch ein Virus, was rumgelaufen ist und die Leute angesteckt hatten. Mussten hier halt ins Krankenhaus. Es gab eine Unterwelt. Techno-Schuppen. Man konnte sich auch an die Bar stellen und Bier und Wodka trinken.
Wie lange lief man da so durch? Was habtet ihr für eine durchschnittliche Verweildauer in so einer Performance?
Es gab drei Generationen. Jede Generation waren so 20 Spielern. Die sind dann sozusagen reingekommen. Wegen der Schule, weil in der Schule haben nur 20 Mann reingepasst. Die erste Generation, die angefangen hat, hat dreieinhalb Stunden gespielt. Die letzte ungefähr zweieinhalb Stunden. Das war der zeitliche Rahmen. Das war ganz schön viel. Viele Leute haben gesagt, hätte auch noch länger gehen können.
Wie ein guter Podcast sozusagen. Habt ihr das mal auf Video? Gibt es da irgendwelche Zeichnungen?
Ich hatte dir einen Link geschickt in einer E-Mail. Aber wir dürfen, ich darf den...
Der ist nur für mich.
Genau, ich darf den leider nicht raushauen, weil dann müssten wir theoretisch alle Leute... Wir haben halt während einer Aufführung ein Kamerateam mit dabei und hat halt die ganze Zeit gefilmt. Aber wir müssten sozusagen eigentlich von jedem... Das Einverständnis abholen und so weiter. Deshalb haben wir da leider nichts. Aber wir haben glücklicherweise vor einer Woche die Zusage bekommen, dass wir die Förderung für eine Wiederaufnahme bekommen von der Stadt Berlin. Das heißt, man hat die Chance, nächstes Jahr im Mai wieder daran teilzunehmen.
Und dann wieder in Oberschweineöde, oder was?
Ja, wir versuchen jetzt sozusagen das gleiche Setup wieder zu realisieren. Also die gleichen Schauspieler, die gleiche Location.
Erinnert mich so ein bisschen an diese wilden Aktionen, die hier auch so im ehemaligen Haus des Lehrers wollte ich jetzt schon sagen, nach Palast der Republik liefen. Kennst du noch diese Aktionen da von der Bergpartei und so? Die haben ja dann auch mal den ganzen Palast der Republik auch in so ein riesiges Spielfeld verwandelt, wo alles Mögliche gleichzeitig stattfand, einschließlich sogar eines Sees. Also sie haben da wirklich noch Teile unter Wasser gesetzt und kurz dann mit kleinen Bötchen irgendwie rumfahren und so. Ich weiß noch nicht ganz genau, wie die Aktion hieß schon eine Weile her.
Nachdem der entkernt wurde, oder?
Genau, nachdem der entkernt wurde und leer war, halt so diese Zwischennutzung. Als auch dieses großartige Zweifel oben auf diesem Palast draufstand. Das fand ich ja eine der geilsten Kunstinstallationen überhaupt. Weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber das fand ich wirklich so dermaßen auf den Punkt. Einfach so riesige Lettern oben auf dem Palast der Republik. Einfach nur Zweifel. Und das fand ich so stark, weil da kommt bei mir echt Zweifel auf. Das ist schon echt supi. Dennis will mal eine Runde Getränke holen gehen. Das finde ich einen sehr guten Einsatz. Ich nehme mal so eine braune Flasche.
Ja, mir auch noch eine braune Flasche.
Hol mir mal eine Flasche Bier, dann streike ich hier. Machen wir mal weiter.
Zwei braune, einmal gelb.
Ich zitierte unseren ehemaligen Bundeskanzler Gerhard Schröder.
Ja, das haben wir alle gemerkt.
Ne, ich brauche die nicht, offensichtlich. Der hat das für bare Münze genommen.
Du musst die Tür... Wir organisieren uns hier erstmal ein bisschen um. Super Aktion, Markus. Also wer Lust hat, auf dem Kongress mitzuschnitzeln, ihr habt die URL. Und wer noch Unity lernen will und coole 3D-App machen will, schreit ja auch so ein bisschen nach VR und wie man ein Modell vom Kongress und so, ne? Ich weiß nicht, ob es überhaupt schon ein 3D-Modell gibt von irgendjemandem.
Gibt es noch keine Counter-Strike-Levels vom CCH?
Ja, wahrscheinlich nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich meine, das wäre eigentlich mal angemessen so.
Counter-Strike live im Kongress, nachts, zwei Teams gegeneinander Gotcha-Pistolen.
Die ganze Hardware kaputt machen oder...
Kollateralschäden gibt es, Abzugspunkte natürlich, falls irgendwie andere abgeschossen werden.
Das können wir dann auf dem übernächsten Kongress machen. Da wird das Ding ja danach abgerissen. Das können wir dann wahrscheinlich...
Vielleicht beim übernächsten schon gerissen?
Danach, ja. Das heißt, wir müssen uns schon wieder was Neues suchen. Und es wird nichts geben.
So.
Wer so sagt, hat noch lange nicht fertig.
Wir haben ja Fans, ne? Wir haben ja Fans in Ollenburg. Das ist jetzt wirklich eine Leckerei. Also es gibt da einen in Ollenburg. Alle Hörer aus Ollenburg jetzt mal hergehört.
Ollenburg.
Spitz mal die Ohren und komm dran auf den Meter.
Genau. Wo hab ich denn den eigentlichen entscheidenden Link? Den muss ich jetzt nochmal kurz raussuchen. Ja, schlecht vorbereitet. Wie immer. Also in Ollenburg, da gibt's irgendwo, ich weiß gar nicht genau wo, aber da gibt's auf jeden Fall einen Laden, der heißt Leffers. Und das ist so ein Klamottenladen. Leffers, Ollenburg. Die sind wohl ganz stolz auf sich. Ja, in Ollenburg hier gegründet, größte Mode aus der Stadt und irgendwie tolle Präsentationen und Szene und Trend-Dabels und alte Menschen, die das gegründet haben und hier schick, schick, schick, schick. Richtig schick. Und naja, und die hatten da wohl so ein paar Deko-Teams am Start, die sich mal richtig was Nettes ausgedacht haben. Und vor allem macht das so den Eindruck, als ob sie, ähm, mal kurz hier mal die Uhr raussuchen, als ob sie alle Hörer der Freak Show sind, weil, ich pack das mal hier kurz in den Chat rein, sie das Freak Show-Logo offensichtlich im Internet gefunden haben und so geil fanden, dass sie es zum Teil ihrer Jugend-Moder-Deko-Ausstellung gemacht haben.
Und kurze Frage, der Typ, der für dich das Freak Show-Logo gemacht hat, der hat es jetzt nicht von da geklaut, ja?
Wir haben da gemeinsam am Tisch gesessen und das irgendwie Linie für Linie uns erarbeitet. Da gab es nun wirklich keine Vorlage. Aber da haben wir ja auch so einen mäßig bekleideten Herrn da mit Zylinder daneben, mit Hund.
Na ja, untermäßig bekleidet verstehe ich dann schon nochmal was anderes. Lange Hose, Unterhemd.
Ist hier einfach Mitte, Hipster irgendwie.
Okay, lass mich anders sagen. Mittelmäßig bekleideter.
Schon besser.
Ja, also das ist jetzt nicht topmodisch, würde ich sagen.
Schwarze Hosen, Träger, Unterhemd und Fliege.
Genau, und Zylinder drauf und dann klebt da an der Wand so das Freak Show Logo. Überlegt man sich natürlich, was machen wir da jetzt? Hier liegt ja auch eine Urheberrechtsverletzung vor. Und was macht man da?
Unter welcher Lizenz ist denn der Podcast veröffentlicht?
Das ist vollkommen unerheblich für das Logo.
Vielleicht haben die gedacht, hier ist Creative Commons, alles klar.
Ach, die haben nicht gedacht, die haben im Internet geklickt, haben Freak Show eingegeben, Bild gesehen, abgespeichert, ausgedrückt. Fettig, so macht man das noch heutzutage. Das finde ich auch irgendwie jetzt nicht so schlimm. Andererseits finde ich, eine ORL hätten sie ja schon nochmal dazu packen können.
Müssen.
Oder den Podcast in der Dauerschleife spielen.
Ja, irgendwas, wenn man ja, womit man Leute auch ganz gut bestrafen kann, ist irgendwie alles so ein bisschen zum Wahnsinn zu bringen. Kennst du diesen geilen Text aus dem Internet, wie man Leute in den Wahnsinn treibt?
Welchen genau?
Welchen Wahnsinn meinen Sie?
Warte mal, das muss ich nochmal kurz nachschlagen. Das ist so ein Web-Klassiker. Ähm, äh, mal Leute in den Bahnzentral. Ist doch hier bestimmt.
Live googeln Sie jetzt mit der Freak Show. Das Freak Show Team googelt für Sie.
Let us Google this together.
Let us Google that for you.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, ob das das Originaldokument ist.
Aber das ist ungeprüft.
Wie man anderen den Wahnsinn treibt. Verlasse das Kopiergerät mit folgender Einstellung. 200% verkleinert auf dem Papier 99 Kopien. Zweitens. Sitze in deinem Garten und zeige mit einem Föhn auf vorbeifahrende Autos, um zu sehen, ob sie langsamer werden.
Ich habe als pubertierendes Kind mit einem Kumpel ein Fotoapparat genommen. Ein Blödsinn-Gerät, meinst du? Wir haben uns auf der Straße hinterm Busch versteckt und dann die Autos angeblitzt. Irgendeiner hat uns das auch gemacht, weil er es nicht witzig fand.
Autofahrer anblitzen ist auch nicht so lustig. Aber was wirklich lustig ist, ist auf irgendwelchen Partys draußen, wo irgendwann die betrunkenen Herren alle zur Hecke gehen, um alle zu hinterlassen, die dann von hinten anblitzen. Einfach nur mit einem Kamerablitz. Ein wunderbarer Freeze-Moment, weil die dann wirklich nicht wissen, ob sie sich jetzt umdrehen sollen oder nicht.
Ist das auch ein Punkt auf der Liste?
Nee, es gibt noch andere lustige Sachen. Fülle drei Wochen lang entkoffinierten Kaffee in die Kaffeemaschine, sobald alle ihre Koffeinsucht überwunden haben. Gehe immer zu Espresso. Schreibe für sexuelle Gefälligkeiten in die Verwendungszweckzeile. Alter, eine Überweisung. Befestige Moskitonetze rund um deinen Schreibtisch. Singe in der Oper mit. Übe das Nachmachen der Fax- und Modem-Geräusche. Antwort auf alles, was jemand sagt mit Das ist das, was du glaubst. Also es sind viele schöne, nette Beispiele drin. Bestehen darauf, die Scheibenwischer in allen Wetterlagen laufen zu lassen, um deren Leistung zu erhöhen. Naja, wenn dich einer fragt, warum du das machst, dann antwortest du dir, um die Leistung zu erhöhen. Das ist wirklich großartig. Rufen zu, falls sein, wenn jemand am zählen ist.
Timmy, du weißt schon, dass die anderen nur lachen, weil du lachst.
Mach die Liste weg.
Ja, mach die Liste weg, genau. Wir haben da Themen abzuarbeiten.
Nee, jetzt musst du erst mal ordentlich abgelachen.
Erst fertig lachen, dann das Bier aufmachen.
Erst ordentlich ausgasen.
Du machst das wirklich.
Das ist so großartig.
Hubo und Fing gefremden zu.
Ich hab früher auch so Nummern gemacht, das ist irgendwie echt lustig.
Beim Marathon.
Ich bin früher immer mit so einem komischen Gerät gebaut, was so Geigerzähler Sound 20 gegeben hat. Da bin ich dann immer durch die Fußgängerzone gelaufen, also nach Tschernobyl. Also so 87 irgendwie, war sehr lustig. Weil alle sehr verunden sich hatten, sehr verunden.
Beim Marathon, beim Skater Marathon stand einer an der Straße, hat immer geguckt, wie die Leute heißen, und dann die Vornamen ins Rennen gerufen.
Das war auch sehr.
Genau das, das ist richtiger Fnord. Genau, also bezüglich Läffers in Oldenburg, dachte ich mir, vielleicht könnten sich ja die Hörer in Oldenburg, es gibt ja vielleicht ein paar, was einfallen lassen. Also ich meine, wenn da allein schon jeden Tag jemand vorbeikommt, und die Verkäufer einfach in ein Gespräch rund um diesen Podcast verstrickt, oder was weiß ich, so Flashmob-mäßig einfach in größeren Gruppen sich dort postieren, um dieses Freak Show-Logo an der Wand und sich dann fotografieren und das schön ins Netz posten.
Du meinst Freak Show und das in Oldenburg?
Wir retweeten das dann, genau. Und dann werden sie halt irgendwann, das erste Mal wird es komisch sein und beim zweiten Mal wird es auch noch komisch sein und beim dritten Mal wird ihnen das langsam ein bisschen merkwürdig vorkommen. Und wenn man dann halt auch das richtige Programm dazu macht, was weiß ich, die Verkäufer mit ihren Vornamen begrüßen, beende alle deine Sätze in Übereinstimmung mit der Prophezeiung. Was machen sie denn da? Wir müssen uns hier fotografieren lassen, in Übereinstimmung mit der Prophezeiung. Und dann werden die halt langsam alles ein bisschen verrückt.
Ja, ich bin dafür, man könnte sich natürlich auch dann noch so Social-Engineering-Fnord mäßig organisieren und ein Wiki aufsetzen und wenn man dann irgendwelche Informationen in den Gesprächen dann da erfahren hat, die in das Wiki posten an die nächsten, die dann da hinkommen, dann sozusagen das Gespräch schon aufnehmen, wo die anderen es verlassen haben. Und lasst Eure Kreativität der freien Lauf, aber natürlich lasst keine Menschen und Waren zu Schaden kommen. Das müsst ich an dieser Stelle nochmal sagen. Aber fnordet sie ordentlich und für jeden Fnord, den ihr leistet, werden wir euch mit Retweets und Preissagungen, Lobpreisungen...
Schickt Fotos und wir prämieren hier nächste Sendung. Fotos von Euch selbst mit dem Schild im Hintergrund. Und umso mehr Leute auf dem Bild sind, umso mehr Punkte gibt's natürlich.
Bestehe darauf, dass du die E-Mail-Adresse Xena Göttin des Feuers entf nname.com bekommst.
Oder poste sie wenigstens in den Chat.
Frag die Leute, welches Geschlecht sie sind.
Das ist übrigens etwas, was man immer sehr schön machen kann bei Kleinkindern oder Babys, die ganz in Rosa angezogen sind, zu fragen, ob es ein Junge ist. Das macht auch immer sehr viel Spaß.
Also Lepfers Oldenburg sind auf jeden Fall die Freaks des Monats. Und ich hoffe, ihr habt jetzt viel Besuch in der Jugendabteilung.
Ja, die sind freigegeben.
Ihr könntet ja auch fragen, ob die T-Shirts haben mit dem Logo drauf.
Das ist eigentlich auch nicht schlecht.
Ja, sowas zum Beispiel.
Also, ja, irgendwie, da sind wir jetzt mal gespannt, wie kreativ unsere Hörerschaft wirklich ist. Und wie gesagt, im Zweifel, organisiert euch noch in irgendeinem Etherpad oder Google-Doc und koordiniert euch so ein bisschen. Und wie gesagt, so ein bisschen Information, dass ihr die dann auch wirklich effektiv fnorden könnt, bis dann irgendwann alle nur noch diese Freak Show hören wollen und verstehen wollen, was eigentlich jetzt Phase ist.
Genau, bis sie dann auch irgendwann mal verstanden haben, was sie da getan haben.
Ja, nicht zu früh spoilern.
Also, und ihr könnt ihr natürlich sagen, dass ihr davon ablassen werdet, wenn sie uns also reichhaltig mit 10.000 Euro jetzt sag nichts falsches, 10.000 Euro gnädigstimmen, dass wir sie nicht auf in Grund- und Bodenfall klagen für diese Kopierrechtsverletzung.
Wenn du Leuten etwas ausleist, ruf sie täglich an und erinnere sie daran, dass sie im Falle eines Defektes das Gerät zahlen müssen.
Das ist aber echt für Leute mit viel Langeweile auch, ne?
Felix, du denkst an mein Firewire-Kabel, ne?
Firewire-Kabel.
Da hat er sich ausgeliehen. Was ist das gleich noch? Ja, da gab es damals so eine Sache, die eigentlich auch besser als USB war, aber ja, wie die Welt immer so ist.
Jetzt weiß ich wieder, was der Originaltext ist. Wie man selbst gesund bleibt und dabei andere Leute in den Wahn enttreibt.
Ja, du bist dabei, Timme.
So, das wäre also Oldenburg in, der Fass in Oldenburg.
Darf ich jetzt hier diese kleine Produktanpreisung zwischenschieben, so als kleines fluffiges Thema, bevor es ernst wird? Also, ich bin ja süchtig nach einer neuen Droge. Also ein ehemaliger Kollege von mir hat gesagt, ach, Computer sind ja doof. Und andere Leute machen schon so viel Bier und ich will auch irgendwas machen. Und hat sich entschlossen, da er glaube ich Amerikaner ist, dass er sein Leben der Herstellung von Beef Jerky widmet. Und ich kannte bisher Beef Jerky nur in so bunten amerikanischen Verpackungen mit jeder Menge komischen Stoffen in der Zutatenliste und auch sehr künstlichen Geschmäckern. Und dann blickte ich sehr skeptisch auf diese Zipbag-Tüte hier, die ich auch gerade vor mir halte, wo Big Texas Beef Jerky drauf steht. Und dann wurde ich aber genötigt, das mal zu probieren und bis hinein und dachte mir, kann ich noch eins haben? Und noch eins und noch eins. Dann war die Tüte auch schon wieder leer. Der Selling-Point von ihm ist ähnlich auch so wie bei den Bieren. Die traditionelle Herstellung ist ja schon längst vergessen. Das müsste man mal wieder richtig machen. In Amerika wird das auch schon richtig gemacht. Und er holt sich halt cooles Fleisch, mariniert das selber, trocknet das ordentlich. Er macht es auch mittlerweile in einem Restaurant, was ihm die Küche dafür nachts irgendwie zur Verfügung stellt. Und ja, es wirbt damit wenig Fett zu enthalten, weil es halt auch wirklich Fleisch ist. Man will halt wohl angeblich bei dieser Herstellung halt kein Fett drin haben, nicht wie in einer Pfanne, weil da macht es eher schlechten Geschmack. Das heißt, es ist fettfrei, weitestgehend und hat halt Proteine und es wirbt auch auf der Seite damit, dass also Sportler, also Leute, die so auf eine Tracking-Tour gehen oder so, dass das wohl irgendwie, das auch schon der Treibstoff der Cowboys war. Ja, ist aber auch auf jeden Fall sehr lecker und passt zum Bier. Und ich dachte mir, der gute Herr, den soll man mal belohnen. Oder nicht belohnen, aber bewerben. Support your local dealers. Also ich krieg keine Provision und nichts dafür, es ist einfach ein cooles... Noch nicht. Ja, vielleicht... Also die Webseite dazu natürlich, wenn ihr euch mal selber dazu informieren wollt, ist btjerky.com. Wenn ihr hier so auf diese What-Is-It-Seite klickt, ich link die auch mal hier in den Chat, dann seht ihr auch, wie das gemacht wird. Und jetzt gibt es hier noch kurz die Live-Verkostung, obwohl wir es schon heimlich gekostet haben. Warte, du kriegst ein größeres Stück, du bist ja hier schon gehuckt. Dennis war noch nicht so überzeugt. Ich war auch super skeptisch, weil ich wie gesagt dieses amerikanische Beef Jerky Zeugs willst du auch noch mal eins.
Ich esse das.
Das ist richtig gut.
Das kommt halt so in einer kurzen...
Das lieben ja unsere Hörer.
Dann jetzt so auf so einem Fleischlappen rumfahren.
Das hat jetzt so was wie die Kochsendung, wo immer das ganze Publikum immer so...
Machen die das?
Ja, furchtbar.
Kochsendung mit Publikum? Also mittlerweile gibt es auf jeden Fall gerade nur die eine Standardsorte. Er macht auch gerade so ein bisschen so ähnlich wie diese Microbreweries verschiedene Flavors. Und es gibt da so handliche Portionchen für kleine Münzen zu bestellen. Das ist auf jeden Fall, ich glaube, besser als Chips, so abends zum Bier vorm Fernseher hocken und so. Und ich muss auch sagen, wenn du so ein kleines Tütchen futterst, und ich hab das irgendwie... Einen Tag habe ich Suppe zum Mittag gegessen, das hat nicht lange gehalten, dann habe ich so ein kleines Tütchen angefangen zu futtern. Und ich war auch echt satt danach. Also es ist schon dieser Spruch, dass das irgendwie so, sagen wir mal, ein bisschen Tinte auf den Föller bringt.
Oh Gott, die Bilder, die gehen auch wieder nicht aus dem Kopf.
Ja, Werner.
Kann ich im Selbstversuch zumindest erst mal teilweise bestätigen.
Zumindest erst mal teilweise.
Ja, und jetzt können wir diese Tüte auffuttern und wir müssen jetzt die Schmatztaste einführen, weil das ist ein sehr schmalko-faziöser...
Ja, die Schmatztaste, die haben wir schon. Den muss man eigentlich gar nicht einführen. Den brauchst du nur benutzen.
Ja, also wenn ihr auch irgendwie mal Beef Jerky in lecker probieren wollt, also ist wirklich, wie gesagt...
Und ist gut mit Bier. Prost.
Ist wirklich ein geiler Snack, muss man sagen. Hat er gut gemacht. Das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt Micro Brewery Bier und Micro Jerkery Jerk. Und dann sind wir aussettelt.
Micro Podcastery Universum.
Rufen Sie jetzt die Nummer neben Ihrer Landesflagge an.
So, wollen wir mal wieder in Digitalien zurückkehren? Ich mach hier erstmal den Jerk weg hier. Tja, weiß nicht, wollen wir schon ein bisschen ranten?
Rant halt.
Na, da raten wir doch alle. Ja, weiß nicht, vielleicht noch mal kurz. Ich war ja mal wieder in einem Apple Store. Das ist ja mittlerweile nichts mehr Besonderes. Die sehen ja auch immer noch alle gleich aus.
Also Apple Store, da muss man doch eigentlich prinzipiell darüber ranten, dass das Konzept nicht funktioniert, oder? Man rennt durch den Store, versucht jemanden irgendwie ranzukriegen, von dem man irgendwas sagen kann. Also das ist ein wunderbares Konzept, bis zu einer bestimmten Füllmenge an Kunden. Und danach bricht es irgendwie komplett.
Ja, aber ist das nicht ein Standardproblem bei allen Läden?
Ja, normalerweise hast du bei einem Laden, da kannst du irgendwo hingehen, nimmst eine Packung aus dem Regal und stellst dich an die Kasse an. Aber das gibt es im Apple Store, das gibt keine Kasse. Außer nicht.
Ziehst du es aus dem Laden, bezahlst mit deinem iPhone, gehst raus.
Na gut, kannst du prinzipiell auch machen, ja. Vielleicht bin ich zu old-fashioned. Auf jeden Fall fehlt dem Laden einfach irgendwie so ein Ansprechpunkt, wo man sich anstellen kann, wenn der Laden voll genug ist, dass es sich theoretisch eine Schlange bildet, weil diese ganzen...
Du willst das genauso haben wie beim Media Markt, oder was? So drei Mitarbeiter pro Etage.
Nein, die Anzahl der Mitarbeiter ist ja okay, nur die sind ja die ganze Zeit unterwegs. Und an jedem hängt ja einer dran und du weißt ja nicht, wo kriege ich jetzt als nächstes was erzählt.
Du hast was falsch gemacht.
Die letzten Male, ich war wirklich nur wenige Male im Apple Store und wollte auch nur einen kleinen Scheiß kaufen, irgendwie einen VGA oder DVI Adapter oder irgend so ein Kram. Und ich bin in München, glaube ich, das letzte Mal rein und dachte mir, ja stimmt, die haben nicht so richtig eine Kasse und es ist voll, weil war auch abends und die Leute sind die ganze Zeit an den Typen dran. Aber in dem Moment, wo ich irgendwie so ein Ding aus dem Regal genommen hatte und dann so kurz im Raum stand und mich umgeguckt habe, kam auch gleich einer, meinte, hier willst du bezahlen, alles klar, komm. Also bei mir war es bisher immer recht fluffig, aber ich war auch viermal im Apple Store oder so bisher.
Keine Ahnung, also ich habe das Gefühl, ab so einer bestimmten Füllmenge funktioniert es nicht mehr. Und das ist irgendwie nicht den Leuten geschuldet, die da arbeiten, weil die tun, glaube ich, ihr Bestes. Aber irgendwie das ganze Konzept, ich bin nicht überzeugt.
Gut, naja, also ich wollte mich jetzt auch nicht von dem Konzept überzeugen, sondern ich hatte diesmal ein konkretes Anliegen, nämlich wollten wir mal diesen iMac 5K anschauen.
Dann fährst du einfach so...
Und das neue, nee, ich war...
Fährst du mal nach Hamburg.
Ich war in Hamburg und bin da gerade vorbei gelatscht und dann bin ich da halt einfach mal reingegangen. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich mir jetzt besonders viel Zeit genommen hätte.
Und wie viele Kopfhörer hast du da getauscht?
Und ich hatte auch ehrlich gesagt, naja, das haben sie ja mittlerweile hinbekommen.
Das haben sie ja mitbekommen, dass du die Kopfhörer hast.
Die gehen ja nicht mehr so kaputt.
Keine Kopfhörer mehr tauschen.
Naja, also sie sind bemerkenswert stabil geworden und das Qualitätsproblem haben sie irgendwie gelöst bekommen. Also zumindest für mich. Ja, weißt du, habt ihr diesen neuen iMac schon mal gesehen?
Nicht in echt.
Er hat echt viele Pixel. Aber das ist dann eigentlich auch schon. Er hat halt viele Pixel. Und man kann ihn nicht als zweiten Monitor benutzen. Von daher ist alles nicht so interessant, aber er hat echt viele Pixel.
Aber ich meine, es gibt jetzt mittlerweile 4K-Displays, auch ab so 4, 500 Euro.
4K, wenn man 5K haben kann.
Aber, um es dazu zu sagen, es ist kein DisplayPort 1.3, wie du mal, glaube ich, irgendwo gepostet hattest, sondern es ist tatsächlich 1.2, overclocked, selbst entwickelt von Apple.
Also der 1.3er Standard als solcher, der steht ja erst vor kurzem fest, aber das ist jetzt belegt, dass sie da den normalen Stein genommen haben und einfach schneller und fertig.
Bisschen übertaktet wohl irgendwie, so wie gerade noch so geht, dass sie gerade ihre 5K perfekt erreichen und fertig. Und alles, was die Leute so schreiben, die Grafikkarten auch von mir, die die gekauft ist, einfach zu langsam, also Spiele und so, könnt ihr alles komplett abschreiben, geht gar nicht.
Wie? Auf dem Rechner?
Das schafft die Grafikkarte bei der Auflösung einfach nicht ganz vergessen.
Du schmatz.
Das heißt, das Ding ist halt gut für, wahrscheinlich für Fotobearbeitung. Bei Video sind sich die Leute noch nie so klar, aber...
Kannst da in 640x320 Pixel spielen.
Aber das ist die Zukunft, auf jeden Fall, würde ich mal behaupten.
Ja, definitiv. Also das ist halt jetzt so mal der erste und macht das Bild extrem klar und irgendwann hätt ich das auch mal gerne, aber derzeit ist es halt einfach Quatsch. Also für mich, also für meinen Zweck auf jeden Fall. Dann hab ich dieses iPad 2 in die Hand genommen.
iPad 2?
iPad 2 Air, iPad Air 2.
Ach so, ich dachte schon.
Entschuldigung.
In guter Form heute hier.
Auf jeden Fall, da geht noch was. Und das war echt leicht. Also das war erstaunlich dünn und das ist langsam, ich glaube. Ich weiß nicht, ich hab mich nicht draufgesetzt. Ich war eigentlich zurückhaltend.
Aber so leicht, wie du jetzt mittlerweile bist, hätte sich das auch nicht verbogen.
Bin ich nicht mehr in der Lage. Ja, na ja, das könnte dann auch daran liegen, weil ich bin dann irgendwie dem Store dann schnell wieder entfleucht, ohne was zu kaufen. Und danach fiel mir aber ein, dass ich ja eigentlich gerade mal eine echte Produktsuche am Start habe. Genau, weil ich wollte nämlich was kaufen. Das fiel mir dann nachher erst an. Dann bin ich dann wieder reingerannt und hab's auch tatsächlich erworben. Ihr seht es hier an meinem Arm.
Ohne Uhr, ohne Uhr.
Es blinkt blau.
Du bist am Leben.
Ist da ein Puls jetzt?
Na, was da blinkt, ist nicht mein Puls, weil wenn das mein Puls wäre, dann wäre ich jetzt nicht...
Dann wärst du cool drauf.
Ja, allerdings.
Deswegen blinkt die blau.
Nee, die blinkt jetzt einfach blau.
Und warum ist die auch unten drunter, wenn ich hier von der Seite gucke, die leuchtet ja da unten. Das ist eine grüne LED.
Das sind zwei grüne LEDs. Und die beiden grünen LEDs machen halt genau das gleiche, was die LEDs bei der Apple Watch auch machen. Die leuchten quasi in meinem Blut. Und irgendwie scannen sie das halt mit so einem Sensor, mit einem Bildsensor, mit so einem CCD und kriegen dann irgendwie die Strömungen.
Und kommt das jetzt auch alles in einem iPhone schon, in diesen Health-Apps und so weiter?
Health-Apps.
Da ist mein... Health. 65.
Ich kann nicht lesbisch.
Nee, ist ja eben nicht lesbisch.
Doch. Health.
Nee.
Also 75 Beats pro Minute habe ich jetzt hier gerade. 64, 66.
Mal sehen.
Und wird es in die anderen Apps übertragen, in das Health...
Health-Apps.
Die Höllen-Apps.
Also das Ding ist, also in diesem Fall habe ich das jetzt mit RunTastic gekoppelt. Diese recht populäre Laufsoftware, die jetzt auch so scheiße nicht ist. Und die kann wohl diese Daten auch in Health ablegen. Allerdings behaupten sie gerade steif und fest, dass das derzeit noch nicht ginge, weil diese Health App noch ein Update benötigt. Nämlich, es gibt da wohl einen Datentyp Kategorie Workout. Und der wird, weiß nicht, entweder nicht übernommen oder nicht angezeigt, eins von beiden. Da weisen sie in den Release Notes drauf hin. Sprich, da ist auch gerade noch viel Arbeit zu tun, offensichtlich für Apple.
Der Markt bricht jetzt gerade los, so ein bisschen, ne?
Jaja, jetzt kommt halt auch so eine ab, nach dem anderen kommt halt mit irgendwelchen Updates, blalala, aber da funktioniert vor allem auch noch das eine oder andere. Ist für mich jetzt auch erstmal ein bisschen irrelevant, weil ich ja dieses Teil nicht den ganzen Tag anhabe. Und es gibt auch keine App, die ich kenne, die jetzt den ganzen Tag meinen Puls nehmen würde. Also das ist ja das, was sie mit der Apple Watch quasi angekündigt haben, dass die Uhr quasi die ganze Zeit deinen Puls nimmt oder das zumindest könnte. Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, habt ihr das noch so im Ohr? Wie das so formuliert wurde, ich meine, das heißt dann, dass im Prinzip den ganzen Tag die LEDs brennen müssen. Braucht vielleicht jetzt nicht so viel Strom, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall ist das meines Wissens zumindest von Workouts jetzt erstmal entkoppelt. In diesem Fall habe ich ja diese Uhr nur mit dieser App gekoppelt. Aber das Gute ist zumindest, diese App weiß jetzt von diesem Gerät eigentlich nichts, außer dass es sich dabei halt um einen Standard Bluetooth-Hardrate-Monitor handelt. Sprich, das ist halt eigentlich dieses Ding, also dieses Armband, ist halt ja auch nur der Speicher dafür. Und da drin ist halt so ein kleines Plasteteil mit diesen beiden LEDs und dem CCD und noch so vier Kontakt-Nubsis, wo man dann halt nochmal so einen Adapter draufsetzen kann, das ist quasi USB zum Laden. Ja, und das mumpelt man halt in dieses Armband rein, damit man es ebenso direkt hier auf der Hand tragen kann. So, das funktioniert, ne?
Wie nah mussten du das am Arm tragen, dass es auch tut?
Ich hab's jetzt noch nicht besonders locker dran gehabt. Also, aber ich hab jetzt auch nicht das Gefühl, dass ich mir da die Blutzufuhr abschnüren muss, um sie zu messen. Also, das ging irgendwie sofort wie gedacht und das hat halt auch sofort gepaart, zumindest jetzt mit der App, die für mich relevant war. Ich vermute mal, dass es auch mit anderen Apps geht, das hab ich aber jetzt bisher noch nicht getestet. Im Store waren sie da nicht so recht in der Lage, mir da eine klare Aussage dazu zu geben, und natürlich ist es so, dass wenn du jetzt die Bedienungsanleitung liest von diesem Produkt, dann erzählen sie erstmal, ja, dann. Also das Ding heißt ja offiziell, hab ich schon gesagt, Mio Link Pulsammern kostet irgendwie Strafgebühr 99 Euro. Es gibt davon auch noch eine etwas more sophisticated Variante, die heißt dann irgendwie Alpha, Blutfuß, Pulsfrequenzmonitor, kostet glaube ich so 160 und die hat dann auch noch ein Display. Das heißt, das hat den Vorteil, dass du da auch deine Herzfrequenz oder deinen besonderen Wert drauf liegst auch immer sehen kannst. Mehr aber auch nicht. Ich wollte halt explizit so ein minimalistisches Teil, was einfach nur mit dem Gerät koppelt, damit man das eben zusätzlich noch mit aufnehmen muss. Die Alternative dazu sind natürlich diese komischen Brustgurte und sowas wollte ich halt auf gar keinen Fall haben. Ja, allein schon das Wort Brustgurt wirft mich so ein bisschen aus der Bar. Ja, ich meine Brustgurt, was soll denn das? Also da komme ich mir da wirklich vor wie auf einer Intensivstation. Das will man einfach nicht haben. Genau, muss sich casual anfühlen. Das war im Prinzip, ich gebe es zu, ich wollte das halt auch so ein bisschen mal ausprobieren, einfach mal sowas.
Um sich schon mal vorzubereiten für die Uhr, die Apple Watch.
Genau, um schon mal was am Arm zu haben.
Um das Ganze mal dicht durchleuchten zu lassen.
Ja, ich hatte einfach schon lange nichts mehr am Arm und das stört gar nicht so sehr. Also das Ding, ich habe es jetzt auch nicht den ganzen Tag um, sondern eben nur beim Laufen. Na ja, und jetzt sehe ich halt, wie sehr ich halt so Hechel in meinen Aufzeichnungen, was an sich ja ganz pfiffig ist. Also wer sowas sucht, alle anderen Puls-Messsysteme, die nicht Brustgurte sind, sind alles so komische Geräte, wo man dann den Finger drauf legen muss. Das heißt, die machen im Prinzip genau das Gleiche. Das heißt, legst du einen Finger drauf und dann leuchten die da rein. Aber das ist mir dann wiederum auch zu bekloppt, dass immer wenn ich dann mal einen Puls messen will, ich dann nochmal so einen expliziten Vorgang machen muss. So klemmt man das Ding einfach an den Arm ran und der Drops ist gelutscht. Und dann kann man Sport machen. Genau, dann kann man nochmal richtig Sport machen. Das mach ich jetzt auch. Das ist ganz gut, funktioniert.
Kaufst du auch noch so eine Waage mit Bluetooth und so?
Ich bin auch noch in der Lage, das Gewicht, was ich ablese vom Display selber, mein scheiß iPhone einzutragen. Da muss ich ja nicht noch so eine Bluetooth-Kopplung vornehmen, um irgendwie drei Digits einzugeben. Da gibt's alles, hier Withings und so weiter, Wi-Fi-Waage, aber ich weiß halt jetzt schon, von welcher Qualitätsgüte diese Wi-Fi-Geräte sind, die in so Embedded-Produkte eingebaut sind. In zwei Jahren perrt das dann wieder nicht mit deinem WPA-Key, weil sich wieder irgendwas geändert hat, und bla, und Security-Loch, und keine Ahnung.
Also du willst Ethernet an der Waage?
Naja, ich meine, die...
Ja, der Trend geht eh zum Kabel, haben wir schon für einige Folgen.
Naja, an der Stelle würde Bluetooth sehr viel mehr Sinn machen.
Aber man muss sie da von Hand perren, das ist auch scheiße.
Hast du eine Bluetooth-Waage, Dennis? Was quatscht bei uns dann hier eine Bluetooth-Waage auf?
Ich hab eine Digital-Waage, ich stell mich da drauf, da steht eine Zahl und dann hab ich irgendwie, dann kann ich einfach das direkt in Health eingeben. Verstehe. Gibt's da einen, ist das irgendwie drin. Also man kann, man kann wirklich, also man kann's echt übertreiben. Also WLAN-Waage, ich weiß nicht, ob's noch, also der einzige Aspekt für eine neue Waage wäre, dass es ja auch noch Wagen gibt, wo du dich da einen Barfuß draufstellst und die dann so einen Stromschluss durch dich durchhagen.
Und dann angeblich Fett messen.
Nee, nee. Nee, das ist so wie bei den Scientology, die irgendwie so in etwa...
Du, wenn du vorher nasse Füße hattest, das ist doch Unsinn.
Ja, das ist wirklich Unsinn. Nee, einfach nur gucken, was die Gravitation sagt und fertig.
Allerdings bei der Waage, man sollte, wenn man eine Waage kauft, sich da dreimal draufstellen und gucken, ob jedes Mal die gleiche Zahl rauskommt. Es ist erstaunlich, wie wenig Wagen das können.
Na vielleicht hast du auch gerade ein bisschen weniger schwere Luft eingeatmet und so. Schwere Luft.
Ein paar Schweratome. Was, gibt's, hast du denn eine Empfehlung für Wagen?
Wie gesagt, außer, dass man sich's mal ausprobieren sollte, ob die tatsächlich taugt.
Ey, ich hab schon so eine lange Odyssee, also die geht schon über ein Jahr, glaube ich. Ich bin auf der Suche nach einer Küchenwaage. Und es ist so unglaublich schwer, eine ordentliche Küchenwaage zu finden, zum Beispiel. Ja, also ich kann mir nur in, nur vorsichtigerweise ausmalen, wie schwer es dann sein muss, eine Körperwaage eine ordentliche zu finden. Weil, also es gibt ja diese Plastikbombe, diese Frickel, wo du die einmal schief anguckst und dann sind sie kaputt. Dann sind die anderen wieder nicht genau, ja. Also ich hätte natürlich gerne eine mit einem Feinwaage-Range für, wenn man mal Backpulver ganz genau dosieren muss.
Wie fein?
Ja, ich hätte auch gerne, also idealerweise auch noch genauer als Gramm, aber...
Noch genauer als Gramm für die Küche?
Natürlich.
Saka, es ist nicht für die Küche.
Hast du noch nie Backpulver abgemessen?
Nein.
Ich auch nicht.
Nein, Grammgenauigkeit reicht schon. Und dann halt am möglichst, aber irgendwas so Metall und stabil und auch den richtigen Range. Also es gibt halt manche, die haben dann nur so einen kleinen Range, dass man halt auch nicht wieder schwere Sachen damit wiegen kann und...
Also bis 5 Kilo sollte gehen.
Umso größer der Bereiche, so näher der Kilo arbeiten kann, umso ungenauer wird's natürlich auch. Ist ja mit Thermometern genau die gleiche Scheiße. Also wenn du so einen Bereich haben willst, würde ich dir glatt und und genau haben willst, dann würde ich eher zwei empfehlen.
Ja, dann empfehlt mir gerne auch in den Kommentaren oder wo auch immer per Twitter irgendwie mal Eure Lieblingsküchenwagen für fein und für grob. Ich bin interessiert, weil bisher haben meine Amazon und was auch immer Recherchen irgendwie nur so Crap hervorgebracht und dann Kaufhäusern, ganz schlimm.
Also ich habe eine Söhne-Plateau-Küchenwaage. Mit der bin ich sehr zufrieden. Ich habe auch eine Söhne-Personenwaage und ich habe auch den Eindruck, Söhne kriegt das mit der Gravitation hin. Das ist nicht die einzige Option bei Söhne. Da gibt es bestimmt alles Mögliche. Ich würde Söhne vertrauen, dass sie das mit dem Wiegen hinkriegen. Aber das Ding macht 2 Gramm Auflösung und macht bis zu 10 Kilo.
Das ist schon ein korrekter Range.
Das Ding habe ich seit Jahren in der Küche stehen und das serves me well.
Dazu brauche ich noch eine feine Waage.
Die musst du extra holen.
Auf dem Kongress haben wir ja eine Feinwaage, um die Geldscheine zu wiegen und die ist sehr genau.
Es gibt außer konsumierbare Substanzen für Feinwagen durchaus einige Anwendungsfälle. Für den Aspiring-Kinder.
Und da Geldscheine auch fettig werden und auch schwer wiegen, die ist so schlau und kann an den Variationen auch...
Was gibt denn so einen 50-Euro-Schein?
Das weiß das Ding.
Aber du nicht?
Nein, das weiß das Ding ja.
Also explizit eine Geldfeinwaage sozusagen.
Nicht nur Geld, die kann auch Münzen zählen, also wiegen.
Münzen sind aber auch Geld.
Aber keine Scheine.
Das ist ja irgendwie sehr naheliegend. Das ist ja echt interessant. Früher hatten wir doch auch so eine richtige Zählmaschine.
Das haben wir auch. Das geht auch. Aber man kann auch das noch mal wiegen.
Und es gibt diese Teile, wo du einfach in den Trichter die ganzen Münzen reinwürfst, dann macht das Ding schromm und sortiert das in so Fächer vor und gibt dir die Summe aus.
So schön ist leider nicht, aber so circa ja. Ne, aber apropos Wagen, ich hab auch zuhause jetzt nicht eine Küchenwaage und auch keine Personenwaage, sondern ich hab mir einfach im Baumarkt so eine Art Kofferwaage geholt. Die wiegt, glaub ich, auch von 10 Gramm oder zumindest, ich glaub, 10 Gramm genau bis 50 Kilo. Ist halt einfach nur so ein Griff wie so ein Koffergriff, außer dass unten halt so ein...
So einen hab ich auch, aber so genau ist sie nicht.
Doch, die ist relativ genau eigentlich, auf 10 Gramm. Ja, doch. Zwei Stellen hinterm Komma bei Kilos und das.
Ja, meine schafft nur eine Stelle hinterm Komma. Aber es reicht, um zu wissen, ob man zusätzlich zahlen muss für einen Koffer.
Nee, ich benutze ja gar nicht für einen Koffer. Sondern ich hab da auch mein Fahrrad mal mitgewogen und irgendwelche anderen Teile, weil alles, was alles, was einen so interessiert, damit man auch mal so ein Gefühl hat, was, wie viel wiegt, weil man liegt da sehr krass daneben, gerade wenn du was Voluminöses hast, dann denkst du, das ist ja eigentlich voll, voll leicht, weil es ist ja so riesengroß und da fällt das Gewicht ja gar nicht so auf, aber da ist halt doch nicht so und andersrum, also das Gehirn wird da sehr doll betrogen und da kann man mal lauter so Sachen durchwiegen und das ist ein großer Spaß.
Ihr seid alle so leicht zu unterhalten, ja, so. Tim endet seine Sätze mit, weil die Prophezeiung jetzt so gesagt hat.
Wer ist der, der die schlechten Witze in die Runde schmeißt und sich da aber einen abfeiert? Und dann sagst du, wir sind leicht so dahin.
Und Dennis sitzt zu Hause und wiegt Dinge und freut sich.
Das ist für die Wissenschaft, man.
Das ist für die Wissenschaft.
Das macht er beim Kongress zu Hause, wiegt er sein Fahrrad, hat er gerade gesagt.
Kann man damit auch Bitcoins wiegen?
Ja, wenn du es auf irgendein Medium packst.
Auf irgendeine Festplatte. Dann weißt du, wie viele Bitcoins da drauf sind.
Aber wiegen kannst du sie trotzdem.
Also ich sehe gerade die Plateau, die ist schon nicht mehr so im normalen Handel. Aber da gibt es ja auch andere Söhne Küchenwagen und die sehen ja irgendwie auch ganz korrekt aus. Surf me well. Ich meine, die müssen ja nicht sehr viel mehr machen als...
Und die ist mit Batterie dann, ne? Natürlich, ja.
Ja, da ist halt eine Batterie drin, die hält ewig. Also, ich hab die noch nie getauscht. Das verbraucht halt alles, kein Strom. LCD, ein Sensor, was willst du mehr? Muss halt nur ordentlich gebaut sein, ordentlich tariert sein.
Das war's. Na gut. Ich gebe Söhne vielleicht mal einen kleinen Vertrauensbonus nach diesem Gespräch.
Ich gebe Söhne eine Chance. Hier gibt es auch noch einen Tipp im Chat.
Ja, wobei da steht nichts an Specks, was irgendwie jetzt mal wichtig wäre. Also, ich verstehe nicht mal genau, wie genau die ist.
Ich finde die haben ganz korrektes Styling. Naja, aber ich denke, die tun das alles. Küchenwagen sind eigentlich ein gelöstes Problem.
Ich würde auch behaupten, sollten auch echt kein Geld mehr kosten, oder?
So, kommen wir zu den ungelösten Problemen. Wie heißt dieses Betriebssystem eigentlich?
Josef's Mieter.
José Mité.
José Mité ist auf verschiedene Computern installiert und eine Marke in Besitzer nicht glücklich. Zumindest, wenn diese Besitzer was mit Audio zu tun haben.
Oder auch Markus schüttelt seinen Kopf. Vielleicht sollten wir Markus mal kurz zwischendurch zum Wort kommen lassen. Als ersten Wortbeitrag, warum hast du dein Jose Miete wieder installiert?
Das Netzwerk hat nicht funktioniert.
Dein Mikrofon steht gerade gegen Uranus. Vielleicht kannst du das...
Mit Netzwerk meine ich... Mit Netzwerk nehme ich an, du meinst das WLAN, oder?
Genau, WLAN hat nicht funktioniert, nichts. Also schrecklich, man konnte nichts mehr einstellen, wenn man den DNS eintragen wollte, hat er, während man geschrieben hat, wieder alles weggemacht und solche Sachen, dann hat der PGP halt auch nicht funktioniert.
Und die Exzente für das Mailprogramm, meinst du?
Genau, die PGPs.
Aber die haben ja gesagt, die dauert ein bisschen und sie sind dabei und kostet aber eventuell und so, aber bet das umsonst.
Bet das umsonst und Ende November muss man dann Geld zahlen, was aber völlig in Ordnung ist.
Ja, ist völlig in Ordnung.
Also bezahle ich sehr gern. Und dann nach zwei Tagen Backup wieder eingespielt und wieder glücklich und kann arbeiten.
Das heißt, du wirst dann warten, bis die GPG Exzente für Mail draußen ist, also irgendwann im Dezember dann?
Mindestens mal, bis das erste Update von raus ist. Also ich glaube, gestern haben wir die Beta vom ersten.
10.1 ist an die Developer geseedet. Da ist auch definitiv der Bluetooth-Treiber. Es hat eine neue Version. Ich denke mal Bluetooth und WLAN, die haben sich da gegenseitig in die Frequenzen geschossen. Und da drehen sie auf jeden Fall dran.
Ja, nicht das erste Mal, dass wir solche Probleme haben nach einem Major-Release. Ja, es sind so die Kleinigkeiten. Ich schätze mal so ein, zwei, drei Sub-Releases muss man schon nochmal abwarten, wo es auch ein bisschen merkwürdig aussieht, ist diese ganze Treiber-Geschichte. Du hast ja letztes Mal berichtet, Dennis, dass sie jetzt auf gesignete Treiber bestehen. Offenbar ist das Feature im letzten Release wieder rausgeflogen. Du kannst jetzt immer noch Anzeigen Treiber installieren. Also es geht auf jeden Fall im Falle von Soundflower. Es ist definitiv kein gesigneter Treiber.
Aber der ist ja auch nicht von Apple. Die Apple-Treiber sind signiert und die werden...
Ne, eigentlich alle Treiber.
Du musst sie jetzt signieren lassen von Apple.
Du musst dir ein...
Developer Key holen, der das darf.
Ja, also du holst den ersten Developer Key und dann schreibst du bitte, bitte, ich möchte Canal Extensions signieren. Und dann liegt es da 3 Wochen rum.
Also es wird schon von Apple gegensigniert. Also dein eigener Key reicht nicht, sondern du musst es schon mal Apple einreichen. Weil sonst könnte natürlich der Trim Enabler-Typ einfach die Canal Extensions von Apple signieren und ausliefern.
Ne, du kriegst einen Developer Key, mit dem du es dann selber machen kannst.
Certificate Signing Request, das ist das, was du machst bei Apple. Und du kriegst dann das Zertifikat von Apple signiert. Und du kannst dann mit dem Zertifikat den Treiber signieren.
Das heißt, wenn sich irgendwer mal so einen Fake-Developer-Account holt und für Canal Extensions sich das alles klarmacht, dann könnte er...
Wieso Fake?
Na, weil danach, wenn er die Apple Extensions signt, die das Trim wiederenablen, dann ist er verbrannt bei Apple, weil sie ihn danach rausschmeißen werden. Aber das könnte man halt einmal machen, und dann ist dieses Ding signiert.
Ja, ich wäre mir dann gar nicht sicher, ob sie es dann... Sie können es dann auf eine Blacklist lassen.
Sie haben auch eine Blacklist, und die meisten Sachen, die da drinstehen, sind irgendwie Antivirus-Kram, weil die alle crashen und so weiter. Also Norton und Symantec, da ist alles drin.
Du musst wahrscheinlich die ID, die Bundle-ID von einem Treiber irgendwie ändern, damit es geht. Aber es müsste eigentlich ganz normal gehen. Du hast ja auch diese Finanzen im Kreuzberg. Wie heißt das Ding? Gatekeeper.
Also ja, Gatekeeper.
Für bla bla bla Entwickler, diese normale Einstellung. Dafür kriegst du ja auch von Apple irgendwie, kannst dir ja auch ein Zertifikat machen, mit dem du das dann signierst. Und wie gesagt, du musst halt den Jungs eine E-Mail schreiben, ich hätte gerne auch für Treiber und so, und dann schalten sie es frei.
Okay, und du musst wahrscheinlich die Bundle-ID freigeben, sonst unterschreiben sie nicht, und du kannst natürlich keine Bundle-ID angeben, die halt von Apple ist, weil da machen sie das nicht, ist ja klar, okay. Sonst könnte man die ja austricksen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du die Bundle-ID nicht einfach ändern könntest, aber vielleicht funktioniert das dann auch nicht.
Na egal. Tatsache ist, das ist irgendwie alles noch ein bisschen unklar, und zumindest Soundflower muss jetzt im Release nicht gesigned sein, um zu laufen.
Funktioniert aber nicht.
Deswegen, vielleicht weil es nicht gesigned ist. Der letzte Ding nehme ich dann einfach nicht.
Dieses Soundflower, äh, Soundflower Soundflower. Dieses Soundflower, ich wollte das ja kürzlich auch mal, also, nee, ich wollte das eigentlich nicht installieren, aber...
Ich musste.
Es gab Anlass, das zu installieren, und dann hab ich mal geguckt, was ist denn jetzt so die Version, die es denn da jetzt so gibt. Und dann hab ich gesehen, dass Rook Amoeba, das ja quasi jetzt unter ihren Schirm genommen hat, aber eigentlich sagt, wir machen nix mehr dran. Ja, das wurde an die übergeben, da gibt es jetzt unter Rook Amoeba slash Soundflower. Und ich glaube auch auf GitHub ist es Rook Amoeba slash Soundflower.
War das nicht ursprünglich von denen?
Ja, oder Cycling 74, irgendwie sowas. Geh mal bei Main, da gibt es so eine Kategorie Freebies, da unten rechts. Ich glaube, da war das irgendwie jetzt mit unten drinne, genau. Und genau, geh mal auf den GitHub-Link, der ist da so links unten. Und da sieht man jetzt zum Beispiel, dass das letzte Mal am 28. März was gemacht wurde. Und dann gibt es ja diese Ultraschall-Edition. Da habe ich dann gesehen, dass jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel passiert, außer diese Presets da oder diese Konfigurationen oder was auch immer sie da automatisch schon anlegen. Interfaces legen sie schon an, wenn du die Ultraschall-Edition installierst. Und dann, wenn man jetzt hier auf diesen Fork-Grafen geht, bei Rook am Möber, dann sieht man wiederum, dass schon ganz viele Leute da schon irgendwas an diesem Soundflower noch drehen. Aber irgendwie ist im Internet oder dem Web nicht zu entnehmen, was denn jetzt eigentlich so die Version ist, die man eigentlich haben will oder... Gehen wir nochmal oben auf das Soundflower da, genau, klickt da nochmal. Achso, du kannst auch schon da oben rechts, wo Fork steht, auf die Zahl klicken. Und dann siehst du den Grafen, welche Version jetzt, wieviel Komits weiter vorne ist und was die Komits sagen. Also du kannst über diese Punkte da oben hovern zum Beispiel, alles, was so weiter rechts ist von dem. Und dann siehst du auch, was die da gemacht haben. Und ja, irgendwie, manche machen halt nur so Kosmetiker. Ich glaube, bei dem einen, bei dem roten oder bei dem blauen, der noch danach kommt, waren auch irgendwas... Bei irgendeinem Fork habe ich auch gesehen, dass sie dann irgendwie neue Zertifikate oder was auch immer machen, dass sie gemacht haben, dass es dann irgendwie bei Apple keine Warning gibt oder... Leute so, ja, alles nur Kleinkram im Wesentlichen, aber es...
Update dazu, also bei Ultraschall ist noch mehr...
Ja, ich habe auch geforkt, aber nichts gemacht.
Also jetzt lass mal den Tim kurz auswählen hier.
Genau, also Ralf und sein Ultraschall-Team, die sind dran an Soundflower und haben im Prinzip sich auch, wie du schon sagst, so einen Key besorgt und so weiter. Und das lief wohl auch alles irgendwie im Prinzip, nur mit dem Release gibt es wohl noch einige Probleme. Außerdem soll da auch noch eine Konfiguration, so ein Kontrollpanel dazu kommen, womit man mal diese ganzen Devices sicherlich zusammenklicken kann. Damit man da nicht irgendwie eine Textdatei in einem Kekst irgendwie editieren muss, sondern du hast halt dann einfach so ein User-Interface und dann kannst du dir dann so Devices anlegen, etc. und auch Mono-Devices und so. Das wird alles ganz nett werden. Und da steht jetzt wohl demnächst ein Release an. Wann, weiß ich nicht genau, weil ich nicht weiß, A, ob es noch Probleme gibt, B, haben wir dieses Wochenendentreffen zu unter anderem diesem Thema und dann wird da wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen das etwas klarer werden. Also da ist auf jeden Fall Besserung in Sicht. Nur alles andere läuft halt nicht. RIPA gibt alles, mit Alben gibt es Probleme.
Also an dem Punkt, wo ich auch Soundflow installieren wollte, musste, habe ich auch noch mal geguckt, gibt es denn da nichts anderes und so. Und es ist auch wirklich, also dieses ganze, was du ja auch schon immer sagst, das ganze Sound- und Audio-Routing ist totales Ghetto. Das ist schlimm. Eigentlich kaum zu glauben, dass das immer noch so der Standard des 21. Jahrhunderts sein soll. Ich wollte nämlich mal dieses Twitch-TV ausprobieren. Weil in Minecraft, also wer nicht weiß, was das ist, das ist diese Webseite, wo diese ganzen Gamer ihre Live-Gaming-Sessions streamen.
Wo die nackt davor sitzen und...
Nicht von dir auf andere schließen, Dennis. Ja, nee, es gibt da auch Leute, die gar nicht da vor die Kamera treten und einfach nur ihr Gameplay streamen. Und bei Minecraft habe ich ja gesehen, dass sie in einer Vision tatsächlich dieses Twitch-Streaming ins Spiel schon direkt eingebaut haben. Also die haben quasi diese Firma gleich mal so ein bisschen mitgehypt, weil die es einfach nativ ins Spiel mit integriert haben. Und dann sagt es aber auf Mac, ja du, damit du hier das Spiel streamen kannst, musst du dir Soundflow installieren. Weil die dann halt auf diese Art und Weise in dein Desktop Audio reintappen und so weiter und so fort. Und es gibt ein anderes Tool, was ich auf diesem Wege gefunden habe, wenn du deinen Desktop streamen willst, also wenn du so ein Live, was auch immer, kannst du ja auch ohne Spiel einfach irgendeine Session machen, Tutorial oder so, gibt es OBS heißt das glaube ich, Open Broadcaster Server oder wie heißt das? Warte mal einen Moment, ich muss mal kurz gucken. Und das ist ein Tool, so ein Screen Grabber im Wesentlichen, der dir halt erlaubt, irgendwie verschiedene Audio-Devices und verschiedene Video-Devices zu bündeln und in den Stream zu kombinieren. Und die auf Twitch oder auf, wie heißt diese andere Streaming-Dienst, muss man gerade gucken, auch so ein ganz bekannter Settings, Stream, Twitch und, achso, YouTube Hitbox. Also alle diese ganzen Sachen sind da schon sozusagen von vornherein irgendwie zum Konfigurieren Streaming-Server. Und dann klickst du auf Start und es streamt los. Gibt es ja auch schon ein Update, super, toll. Und das einzige Problem ist natürlich das Audio. Weil der kann natürlich das interne Mikrofon super, aber sobald du irgendwelche externen Audio-Interfaces oder sowas haben willst, geht das auch nicht. Musst du wieder mit Soundflower anfangen, dir irgendwie virtuell was zusammenzustöpseln. Es ist ein Schmerz sondergleichen. Und das könnte mal gefixt werden, aber gut, wenn das in Josef Mité, in Josef Mité, José Mité auch nicht gefixt ist, dann gibt es auch einen Grund, jetzt, oder keinen Grund, das Upgrade zu forcieren. Und du hast schon Reaper ausprobiert und das ist auch kaputt.
Ich hab ne, nee, Ralf hat's ausprobiert und meint, es gäbe auch Ärger. Also der Ärger ist vielschichtig und...
Vielschichtiger Ärger.
Es gibt auch gute Berichte, also er meinte, er hätte auch... Du hast ja auch gesagt, Focusrite, bei dir alles supi. Er hat ein Focusrite-Interface, alles überhaupt nicht supi.
Nee, nee, ich hab nicht gesagt, alles supi. Ich hab gesagt, sie haben die Software... Also sie haben diesmal schon direkt zum Release ihr Mix-Control für die etwas advancederen Interfaces gleich bereit. Also ich weiß nicht, wenn ihr diese Roten, diese Scarlet hat, da braucht man das glaube ich, oder hat man das nicht? Da braucht man ja keine Treiber installieren für, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, also ich muss das nicht. Und für mein dickes 19 Zoll Interface, da kriegst du dann so eine Routing Software halt auch dazu. Und da musst du auch Treiber installieren und das hatten sie in dem Fall auch für José Mité gleich am Start. Aber ich hab's halt noch nicht ausprobiert. Ich weiß nicht, was Ralf für ein Interface hatte, wenn er so ein USB-Interface hatte, dann könnte es sein, dass es da vielleicht noch Probleme gibt.
Aber so sieht's aus und ich hab auch von vielen anderen Interfaces gehört, dass Probleme gibt's, alles wieder da mit Knacksahnen und das volle Programm. Das Einzige, was wohl sehr gut funktioniert, ist der Zoom H6. Der ohnehin keine eigenen Treiber braucht, Multitrack, out of the box funktioniert und der hat wohl keine Probleme. Hab ich aber auch noch nicht ausprobiert, weil ich meide José noch durch die Bank auf allen meinen Systemen. Weil ich ehrlich gesagt das schon abkommen sehen und ohne Hinweis, dass vieles dann nicht laufen wird und bevor da nicht PGP geht und bevor da nicht irgendwie das mit dem Audio zum fünften Mal gefixt ist, gibt es für mich irgendwie überhaupt keinen Grund. Ich mag den Look auch immer noch nicht.
Das Einzige, womit ich da massiv Probleme habe, ist irgendwie Skype. Oh, das kann natürlich auch an Skype liegen.
Dieses babyblaue Skype da. Das hab ich gleich wieder weggeschmissen. Das ist auch ein Downgrade-Wert.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, man macht das auf und dann hast du Angst, wenn ich nicht aufpasse, dann schalte ich es auf rosa. Das ist so eine Babyversion irgendwie. Das ist doch ganz schlimm.
Also gut, abgesehen davon, dass die Farben unerträglich sind, könnte ich damit ja noch leben, aber sie haben halt auch so absurde Dinge gemacht, wie dass die Fensterbreite jetzt limitiert ist. Also egal wie groß du dein Fenster aufziehst, der Chat wird nicht breiter.
Ja, und so fürchterliche Sprechblasen im Chat.
Das ist furchtbar. Ich weiß nicht, was Microsoft da gerade reitet, aber das ist einfach...
Obwohl das Einzige, was besser geworden ist, ist dieser Feedback-Dialog kein Feedback-Dialog mehr, sondern wenn der Anruf beendet ist, dann kriegst du so 5 Sternchen, wo du anklicken kannst, wie viele Sternchen du jetzt der Verbindung gibst, und dann ist das Thema auch gegessen. Dann kriegst du nicht diese Seite mit...
5 Sterne Beurteilung funktioniert nicht.
Das ist noch mal was anderes, aber wenigstens ist dieser formatfüllende Dialog weg, wo man erst abbrechen drücken muss und so weiter.
Das ist wirklich schlimm. Ich weiß auch nicht, was das noch werden soll mit Microsoft. Ich hab da ehrlich gesagt keine Hoffnung.
Hoffentlich lassen die das Minecraft in Ruhe.
Wer José installiert hat, aber José nicht vertragen kann, weil er keinen Retina-Bildschirm hat und sich nach seinem alten System von zurücksehend, da gibt es auch Abhilfe. Da hat nämlich einer auf GitHub gepostet. Unter dem schönen Titel Lucida Grande José Mité. Schreiberstein heißt der Autor offenbar. Das ist eine kleine Automator-Geschichte. Da startet man wieder seinen alten Font. Dann ist alles gut. Man muss sich nicht das hässliche Vittica angucken. Also hässlich in niedriger Auflösung hässlich. Das noch mal als Tipp nebenbei. Habe ich selber nicht ausgetestet, aber Gerrit war begeistert auf Twitter.
Da kann man einfach mal sagen, ich habe ja Retina und ich mag ja das Times New Roman insofern. Quatsch, wie heißt das?
Elvetica Neue.
Auch irgendwas mit New.
Jetzt sind wahrscheinlich auch wieder einige vom Fahrrad gefallen.
Irgendwas mit Neue.
Irgendwas mit Neue. Ich habe hier das absurde Problem, dass ich jetzt Pre-Releases im Updates, Upstor-Updates-Angebote bekomme. Ich könnte jetzt hier Seat 10.10.1 14B7 installieren.
Wow, da habe ich schon viel Gutes drüber gehört.
Genauso viel Lust habe ich da drauf. Wifi wird aber besser.
Für Feinschmecker.
14B17, nicht 14B7.
14B17, ja, meinetwegen.
Dann ist es schon mal 10 Redo weiter.
Nee, nee, das habe ich hier auch.
Ach so.
Dieses Beef Jerky, das geht auf die Konzentration.
Du hast ja eine eigene Bildnummer, oder?
Wir haben es ja bald geschafft.
Ich glaube, alle, die die Betas installiert haben, die kriegen jetzt auch die Betaseats, aber es gibt die nächsten Angebote von Apple.
Dennis, was hast du denn noch entdeckt?
Du hast es da eingebaut, aber es gehört da gar nicht hin. Weil Dark Wake mit José Mité nichts zu tun hat. Das Problem gab es auch schon bei Mavericks.
Ich sehe da aber was mit José Mité, deswegen...
Okay, der linkt dir nicht ab, aber das ist eigentlich falsch.
Du meinst, das gehört jetzt hier in deinem Spezialsegment?
Nein, auch nicht. Das ist einfach extra. So wie jetzt ist es gut. Aber wenn wir jetzt schon mal dabei waren, kann ich ja auch drüber erzählen, ist ja eine Software-Sache. Also mir ist... Ich glaube, ich hatte das auch in der letzten Sendung schon. Ich hab das Problem, mein Mac wacht alle eine Stunde, 50 Minuten wacht er auf, macht irgendwie was und geht wieder aus. Und ich meine, das ist vielleicht, wenn man eine SSD hat, nicht ganz so schlimm, oder ein Laptop und so weiter und so fort, aber bei so einem Mac Pro mit irgendwie vier Platten drin, das macht auch echt eine Menge Krach, weil das Ding ist laut. Und das muss halt nicht sein, weil auch Platten mögen das nicht so. Der Tag hat 24 Stunden, das Ding heißt, das fährt irgendwie 12-, 13-mal am Tag geht das Ding an und wieder aus. Und Platten mögen nicht so oft hoch und runter fahren, und das muss einfach nicht sein. Und ich hab geguckt und gemacht und hab auch andere Leute gefunden, die das gleiche Problem haben. Und das ist noch nicht komplett gelöst, aber der Gegner ist schon ziemlich umzingelt. Und zwar ist es der Discovery Demon. Man muss dazu sagen, es gab ja früher den M-DNS-Responder auf Mac. Das ist der Multicast DNS-Responder. Das ist halt so ein kleiner Demon, der so ein bisschen auf Proxy spielt für alle Geräte, die halt Bonjour sprechen. Der übernimmt dann die Jobs sozusagen dafür und kümmert sich. Und den gibt's nicht mehr unter Yosemite. Der heißt jetzt halt Discovery Demon. Und der jedenfalls, nach diesem Link da zu urteilen, ich hab da so einen Link gepostet, den können wir vielleicht auch mal in den Chat schmeißen, der meint, wenn man in der PList-Datei, also wo jeder Prozess oder Demon braucht, damit er von Launchday gestartet wird, hat er so eine PList, wo halt auch die Konfig reingeklatscht werden kann. Und der meint, der hat einfach eine zusätzliche Konfig reingeklatscht, nämlich die Minus-No-Multicast oder so. Und dann wacht der Rechner schon mal nicht mehr auf, das Problem ist nur, dass dann auch ganz viele andere Sachen nicht mehr funktionieren. Und das ist noch nicht die Lösung. Also gerade wenn man halt auch WLAN benutzt, wohl die WLAN-Anzeige funktioniert dann nicht mehr, wahrscheinlich Handover-Continuity, da könnte auch sein, dass da eine Menge nicht mehr funktioniert. Hier AirDrop, wahrscheinlich benutzt ihr auch Bonjour-Services und so weiter und so fort. Du findest die Drucker nicht mehr, du findest deine WLAN-Station nicht mehr, wenn du sie administrieren willst und so weiter. Also das ist noch nicht die richtige Lösung, aber er hat zumindest schon mal den Discovery-Demon festgenagelt, dass der schuld ist, weil es liegt wohl da dran, dass der Discovery-Demon der Airport-Express-Station, wenn man denn eine hat, der Bescheid sagt, dass hier jetzt so ein Rechner ist, der so und so heißt, und jetzt aber schlafen geht. Und die Airport-Express spielt dann Proxy für diesen Rechner und sagt, der ist hier im Netz vorhanden. Und wenn dann jemand sagt, okay, ich würde mich gerne mit AFP, also hier Apple File Sharing Protocol, dahin verbinden, dann sorgt die extrem dafür, dass dieser Rechner wieder aufwacht, weil die schickt dann wahrscheinlich dieses Wake-On-Paket irgendwie raus, um den Rechner zu wecken und so weiter und sofort. Und ja, ich weiß nicht, mein Mac Pro, der steht da ziemlich stabil und der ist nach zwei Stunden nicht weg und nach 20 wahrscheinlich auch nicht. Das heißt, eigentlich muss mein Rechner nicht der Express alle zwei Stunden sagen, ey, ich bin noch da, ich bin noch da, ich bin noch da. Das ist halt nervig. Oder zumindest ich will dieses Feature nicht, dass das Ding so oft aufwacht und ich werde weiter suchen und gucken, bis ich das da irgendwie weg habe. Und in diesem neuen 10.10.1 Beta, wovon wir gerade gesprochen haben, habe ich auch vorhin extra noch mal schnell getestet. Da ist das Problem auch nicht gelöst.
Ja, sieht auch aus wie so ein Problem, was Apple auch gar nicht lösen will.
Doch, ich glaube schon.
Das sieht mir aber auch...
Am schlimmsten Fall rufe ich bei Greenpeace an, weil es ist eine riesen Stromverschwendung. Weil die Platten gehen schneller kaputt, das braucht mehr Strom, das ist einfach bekloppt.
Also ich will das nicht. Im Zweifelsfall hat das nichts mit Dark Wake zu tun, weil der Rechner wacht ja richtig auf.
Nee, der Bildschirm wacht aus, deswegen heißt es ja Dark Wake.
Ja, aber so wie ich damals Dark Wake verstanden habe, funktioniert es sowieso nur mit der SSD, weil der Rechner wacht nur so ein bisschen auf, macht keinen Lüfter an, macht sonst nichts.
Das ist vielleicht bei den Laptops so. Vielleicht ist es ja auch der Fehler, dass es halt nur bei Laptops so sein sollte, aber der Mac Pro macht es halt auch. Und das müssen die halt mal fixen.
Ja, gut, ich fände das jetzt nicht so schlimm, aber...
Ja, weil du machst deinen Rechner auch immer ganz aus, nehme ich an, was du gesagt hast beim letzten Mal.
Ganz oder gar nicht, genau.
Nee, ich lasse ihn halt immer im Sleep Mode. Der ist dann schnell wieder oben.
Ja, ich habe extreme Instabilitäten aus Sleep Mode. Also entweder wacht er nicht auf oder...
Ja, dann liest du schon wieder an deinen komischen Treibern und so weiter.
Ja klar, aber das kann da auch sehr gut dran gehen.
Nee, mein Rechner wacht eigentlich, also da ist alles einwandfrei.
Bei deinem Rechner ist alles einwandfrei. Dann gucken wir nochmal, wie wir die Kiste noch ein bisschen gepimpt bekommen, oder?
Ja.
Dann müssen wir mal hier gleich.
Wieder alles runtergefallen. Also ich bemühe mich ja jetzt, wenn Timmer sich schon mühe, gibt es so einen schicken Jingle, dass ich jede Woche was habe, jede zwei Wochen, biweekly. Und zwar habe ich ja schon öfter erzählt hier Grafikkarte und so weiter und so fort und Mac Pro. Ich hatte halt nur so eine uralte GT120 war da irgendwie drin, Ultralarm. Dann habe ich von meinen Bitcoin Minern so eine AMD 5870 in mein Mac geschmissen. Schon ordentlich flott. Ich sei halt auch schon ein bisschen alt, aber es tut eigentlich. Ich war eine Top-End-Karte damals, aber die hat halt keinen Boot Screen Support. Das heißt, weil die nur einen BIOS hat halt und keinen EFI BIOS. Siehst du halt beim Booten nichts, weil der EFI Bootloader will natürlich da auch EFI Treiber sehen und die hat die Karte nicht, also kommt beim Boot nichts. Das heißt, der Bildschirm erscheint erst, wenn der Grafiktreiber geladen ist. Und also beim Locken siehst du sie dann erst. Das heißt auch wiederum, dass du, wenn du File Vault benutzt und du musst bei der Boot, also beim Bootloader schon, dein Passwort eingeben, damit deine Platte entschlüsselt werden kann. Das geht nicht, weil du siehst nichts. Musst dich immer blind machen, ist nicht so schön. So, dachte ich jetzt, alles klar. Gibt es ja hier netcast.org. Die hacken ja irgendwie Grafikkarten, schreiben Treiber Neuen, machen und tun. Und dann habe ich mir jetzt eine, was war es, eine Gigabyte R9 280X geholt. Ist jetzt auch nicht mehr so der neueste Scheiß, aber rockt ganz ordentlich. Ja, hab die geflasht. Das heißt, der Anfang der Karte, also das Anfang ist das normale BIOS für Windows. Das bleibt drauf. Aber im hinteren Teil, wo noch Platz ist in diesen 120 Kilobyte, da kommt halt dann so ein EFI-BIOS hin. Und das wird da hinten ran geflasht. Und dann hat die Karte auch Bootscreen. Das war erstmal das erste. Die zweite Sache ist dann, dass die Karte default im PCIe1-Modus ist. Das heißt, sie ist von einer Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit von Rechnerindikate, also Memory-Speed sozusagen, in die Karte rein, ist nur die Hälfte, zweieinhalb Gigatransactions pro Sekunde. Und da gibt es auch so einen Trick, man muss, ich weiß nicht, wie die Jungs das rausfinden, das ist alles ein bisschen schräg, wahrscheinlich durch auch viel ausprobieren und von vielen Leuten, die keine Ahnung haben, aber trotzdem suchen, machen, tun, bis sie es finden. Und zwar muss man den Widerstand R17, von dem ich letztens auch getwittert habe, wo die Leute gefragt haben, was es denn ist, man muss den Widerstand R17 auslöten. Ich habe da auch das Bild getwittert, wie klein der ist, also im Gegensatz zu einem Streichholzkopf. Also ein Streichholzkopf würden wahrscheinlich ein paar hundert von diesen Widerständen reinpassen. Den habe ich ausgelötet und warum auch immer. Jetzt wird die Karte als PCI 2.0 erkannt und schafft jetzt 5 Giga Transactions pro Sekunde. Bringt irgendwie 3, 4 Prozent in so Grafikbenchmarks.
Hat sich ja voll gelohnt.
Ja, also für einmal kurz auslöten finde ich schon. Und wenn man schon rumbasselt in seiner Kiste, dann will man das ja auch richtig machen. So, dann das dritte war, als wenn man so eine Karte hat, will man natürlich ein bisschen ausbilden und so weiter und startet Benchmarks. Und es gibt unter Windows einen Benchmark, der ist in den PC-Zeitschriften und überall ist der sehr berühmt berüchtigt. Und zwar der sogenannte Furmark Benchmark. Das ist so ein Donut aus Haaren, der sich so dreht.
Ein was? Ein Donut? Ein Donut aus Haaren.
Ja, das ist so ein runder... Furmark, F-U-R. Genau, und dieser Benchmark, wenn du den unter Windows startest, also es gibt schon viele Leute, die haben sich auch ihre Rechner damit zerstört, weil irgendwie alles unter, also nicht unterbemessen war an Stromversorgung oder an Hitzeabfuhr und so weiter. Der braucht halt, alles was die Grafikkarte zur Verfügung stellen kann, das braucht dieser Benchmark. Also es wird scheiße heiß, es verbraucht verdammt viel Strom. Und wenn dein Rechner das nicht aushält, dann geht der entweder kaputt oder das Netzteil, irgendwelche Sicherheitsfeatures sorgen dafür, dass sich dein Rechner ausschaltet. Oder wenn deine Grafikkarte auch sonst wie schon Hitzeprobleme hat, dass dann halt Grafikfehler kommen und so weiter und so fort. Und den habe ich gestartet und mein Mac Pro ging aus. Und zwar war das Problem, ich kann Timme damit, weil wenn du da nichts findest, kann ich das gerne mal hier auf meinem Rechner kurz und klein starten. Das sieht dann hier so aus.
Das ist aber eklig.
Das ist einfach nur ein Donut mit ganz vielen Haaren, was halt für eine Grafikkarte viel Arbeit ist.
Das sieht ja aus wie Goatzi.
Da fehlen aber noch die Hände.
Das ist ein Bagel aus Härchen. Das ist so eklig. Anus Mark hätten sie das Ding nennen können.
Ist egal, es ist ein guter Benchmark, um den Rechner zu testen.
Selbstschutz. Und zwar das Problem ist, diese Grafikkarte braucht einmal, gibt so PCI-Stecker, die für Strom zuständig sind. Und der Mac hat davon nur zweimal 6 PIN. Und diese Grafikkarte braucht aber einen 6 PIN und einen 8 PIN. Und der 8 PIN, der will halt 150 Watt haben, diese 6 PINs können aber nur 75 liefern. Und dann habe ich mir halt von dem einen Stromstecker auf der Grafikkarte zu dem anderen Stromstecker auf der Grafikkarte die beiden 12 Volt-Leitungen miteinander verbunden, sodass die Last jetzt gleichmäßig auf meine beiden 6 PIN verteilt wird und nicht einer voll viel belastet wird und der andere nur normal. Und jetzt stört es auch nichts mehr ab. Das heißt, meine Karte ist jetzt Rock'n'Roll stabil. Also, wer seinen Mac Pro updaten will, zusammenfasst und kauft sich eine Gigabyte Windforce, tralala, R9 280X, flasht die, indem man bei Netcast irgendwie nach dem entsprechenden Thread sucht, wo man halt dieses Flash da kriegt und liest sich das ordentlich durch. Weil wenn man es falsch macht, hat die Karte kein Bios mehr, das kann man fixen, aber nur wenn man noch eine zweite Grafikkarte hat, sonst sieht man nämlich nichts. Und ob man dann, die kostet 240 circa. Und die ist relativ leise, weil sie hat drei Lüfter, die drehen relativ langsam und sie sind ja nicht auch so klein, sondern sind schon groß. Das heißt meine 5870 mit weniger Power war deutlich lauter. Also die ist ganz entspannt.
Und die kommt out of the box. Also man muss jetzt noch einen Jumper umstecken?
Nee, man muss eine R17 auslöten. Wer Probleme hat, mit R17 zu finden, es ist auch alles beschrieben, wenn man lange genug suchte. Aber ansonsten, nimm deine Grafikkarte, komm in den Berliner Club, ich löte R17 aus. Und wenn dein Rechner abkackt, weil Vormarkt doch ein bisschen heavy ist, dann löte ich auch die Brücke.
Dann mach ich dir krass, löte ich dir wieder rein, löte ich dir raus.
Ich löte auch eine Brücke von dem einen 12 Volt-Pin auf den anderen. Das kostet aber zweimal Getränk. Und Timme, für dich, weil du meintest immer, du willst HDMI haben. Ich habe alle vier Ports, die Karte hat einen DVI-Port, einen HDMI-Port und zwei Mini-Display-Ports. Und ich habe meine Karte mit Adaptern an allen vier, also mein Display an allen vier Ports probiert mit Adaptern. Und alle vier gehen zumindest einzeln, ob die auch gleichzeitig gehen, kann ich jetzt noch nicht sagen, aber ich gehe davon aus.
Mit HDMI.
Ja, hatte nur einen HDMI, aber habe ich probiert, ging.
Du kannst ja bei Display-Ports auch HDMI anschließen, mit einem Adapter.
Ja, was für Adapter ich danach hinterhabe, ist ja immer das gleiche Signal. Aber diese Ports, da wo es was rauskommt, da kommt was.
Da kommt auch was raus.
Was war der vierte Port?
DVI, HDMI, zweimal Mini Display-Port.
Ja, naja, ich sehe jetzt noch nicht so ganz hier den Vorteil für mich, weil es läuft ja, außer dem Boot.
Ich habe Boot-Screen, genau. Das war schon wichtig, weil ich benutze halt File-Word und ich habe immer nichts gesehen und es nervt noch ein bisschen.
Für Marc. Das kommt mir nicht nochmal auf den Bildschirm.
Also, wenn Leute sagen, sie haben ihren Rechner dick übertaktet oder eine coole Grafikkarte, bei denen einmal Vormark starten, wenn der Rechner überlebt, dann haben die Leute ordentlich gebastelt. Wenn er ausgeht, dann ja, war es Schrott. Dann, nächster Punkt, vielleicht wieder für dich interessant, weil du hast dir schon mal eine USB-3-Karte für dein Mac geholt. Und die ist bis heute nicht angeschlossen, richtig, weil die will Standard-Molex-Strom wie von früher haben und hat der Mac natürlich innen drin nicht und deswegen hast du sie nie benutzt. Es gibt jetzt auch eine, also nicht nur eine, sondern eine USB-3-Karte, die keinen Stromanschluss mehr braucht. Und die auch, es gibt für USB-3 so ein Standard, jetzt hab ich leider den Namen vergessen, irgendwas mit... Nee, den nicht, sondern was für, damit Festplatten noch so ein Stück schneller sind. Und das unterstützt die auch, das gibt's auch schon vor lange, aber das hat die auf jeden Fall. Ich guck mal kurz hier, wo die... Ja, damit die irgendwie besser performen. So, das ist das hier, ist es das? Ja, genau, UASP heißt das. Das sorgt dafür, dass Festplatten auch wirklich den Speed kriegen, den das USB-3 halt hat. Und hier ist ein Link, wo halt, ist das auch der richtige Chat jetzt hier? Ja, es ist, zack, hier ist ein Link, wo halt der State von USB-3 sozusagen immer wieder neu besprochen wird und der listet im ganz ersten Thread am Anfang auf, welche Karten was können, wie gut die sind und ob die externe Strom brauchen oder nicht. Und die sagen halt, was treiberlos im Mac Pro funktioniert. Und ja, da kann man sich so eine Karte dann holen. Da sind Leute, die sagen, hier funktioniert, funktioniert nicht. Die testen dann alles Mögliche durch. Ist aber, glaube ich, immer noch nicht ganz perfekt. Weil, eine Sache habe ich da nämlich gelesen. Und zwar gibt es so ein Problem, wenn man den Rechner in den Sleep Mode versetzt, dann werden die Platten ejectet. Und nach dem Sleep Mode kommt dann eine Meldung, dass die halt nicht ordentlich ejectet wurden, weil er sozusagen einfach den Strom wegnimmt. Das ist noch ein bisschen bekloppt, weil das hat ein normaler Mac irgendwie nicht. Der fährt die halt runter und holt danach wieder hoch die Platten. Und das sollte ja so nicht sein. Das ist also noch nicht perfekt. Finde ich noch nicht so gut. Weil natürlich will ich meinen Rechner runterfahren, ohne jedes Mal die Platten zu unmounten zu müssen. Die Externe ist ja bescheuert.
Ja, ich brauche auch eigentlich keinen USB 3.0.
Ja, so eine Externe Platten, das ist schon flott, muss man schon sagen. Also gerade mit diesem UASP, da geht es schon echt ab.
Na ja, Gott, dann brauchst du halt auch schnell Platten, aber die stecke ich halt eh in meinen Mac Pro rein.
Na, ich sage ja nur, für Leute, die es brauchen. Ich habe so ein Ding auch noch nicht.
Passt schon.
Hab auch noch keine USB-Extender oder Gehäuse oder sonstiges. Also nicht mit 3.0 auf jeden Fall.
Und Roddy, wie sieht es da bei dir aus mit deiner USB 3.0-Kompatibilität?
Nein.
Du verhältst dich hier so verdächtig ruhig in der Ecke. Da setzt er sich erstmal die Brille ab.
Nö, eigentlich. Ich habe so eine kleine USB 3.0 Festplatte zum Backupen. Wenn ich auf Reisen bin. Ansonsten kann ich zur USB 3.0 nicht viel sagen.
Ich habe es aber...
Ich will es nicht.
Man hat es und man redet nicht überall.
Aber du hast es doch an deinen Mobilgeräten.
Ich warte auf Thunderbolt 3 oder am besten 4. Dann funktioniert der Scheiß wenigstens.
Ich habe letztens so einen Thunderbolt-Doc das erste Mal in echt gesehen. Das gibt es wirklich.
Und wie teuer war es? 300 oder 400 Euro?
Ich glaube, es war das Belkin-Ding, was es halt kostet. Ja, mehr Straf als Gebühr. Aber immerhin gibt es das jetzt in the wild. Tatsächlich, ich meine, wie lange hat das gedauert, bis dann mal die ersten Thunderbolt-Geräte. Oh, und fällt mir gerade ein, von irgendeiner Audio-Interface-Bude gibt es jetzt auch so einen kleinen USB-2-Mikrofon-Preamp-Audio-Interface. Das gibt es von allen, von Focusrite und so weiter. Letztens habe ich eins mit Thunderbolt gesehen und das habe ich mir gebuckmarkt und vergessen. Okay, wie heißen denn die großen Hersteller von diesen? Ah, hier von Zoom war das. Weißt du, die diese Stereorecorder machen? Da war ich nämlich auf der zoom.co.jp-Webseite und da habe ich gesehen, dass das Thunderbolt...
TAC2.
Genau, gibt es jetzt.
Wie zwei Kanäle und dann über Thunderbolt? Was soll das denn?
Ja, 96 Kilo oder...
Ordentliches Timing.
Kein Geknackse.
Wenig Latenz.
Blazing Speed, Amazing Sound.
Also ich meine... Also der macht sogar 192 Kilohertz. Das kriegst du nämlich bei den USB-Devices nicht hin sonst. Ich meine nicht, dass man es brauchen würde, aber...
Ja, genau. Nicht, dass man es brauchen würde. Das ist genau der Punkt.
Aber es... Also ich finde, es sieht ganz schnuffig aus, das Interface. Also wenn sie noch einen ordentlichen Kopfhörer-Preamp reingemacht haben, dann wäre das auf jeden Fall eine Alternative jetzt mal.
Wieso hat er nicht oder was?
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Das ist ja immer oft das... Was kostet denn sowas? Das ist oft das Problem bei diesen kleinen USB-Schnuffe-Interfaces, dass dann die Power halt nicht reicht, um dann ordentlichen Mikrofon-Preamp irgendwie, oder die bauen einfach Scheiß ein. Gucken wir mal bei Toman würde ich sagen.
Man bemerke auch den Zoom-Tag 2 und Apple Mac OS X-Rosé Mité Update.
Wichtiges Noten für Tag 2-R-User, bitte nicht mit dem Tag 2-Update mit José Mité update.
Audio ist immer wieder hart.
Ich finde das schon absolut bemerkenswert. Aber noch bemerkenswerter für mich, dass sie überhaupt so etwas machen. Also das ist schon mal ganz interessant.
Was, ein Stereo-Audio-Device über Thunderbolt?
Ja, überhaupt.
Ich finde das absurd sinnlos.
Ja, aber ich mag halt so USB-Audio nicht so gerne.
8-Kanal, okay.
Ja, das ist halt der Anfang, das gibt es ja jetzt bald.
Aber 2 Kanäle, das ist so, was soll das? Und dafür verbrate ich dann ein Thunderbolt-Port? Das ist doch sinnlos.
Naja, wenn du halt das ganze Geknackse nicht haben willst.
Es geht ja.
Hast du ja trotzdem, schreiben sie ja.
Bei José Mité hast du das auch, ja.
Also ich hab dieses 2-Kanal-USB-Scheißteil von, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie die Firma hieß, irgendein IO2, das kam oder so, mit einem Plastikbomber. Zum skypen, super, tut einfach.
Ja, ja, natürlich. Also es geht alles irgendwie, mehr oder weniger gut oder schlecht dabei.
Hat auch Phantom-Speisung, ne, für ordentliche Mikros und so.
Also ich fände natürlich auch schöner, wenn ihr zum Beispiel Focus write, deren Pre-Ams ja ich ja an sich total schön klingend finde, wenn die jetzt mal auch statt nur USB-Devices auch mal, also die haben ja Firewire früher gemacht natürlich, und die wagen sich auch nur sehr zaghaft an das Thunderbolt heran. Ich fände das schon jetzt mal ganz gut, wenn es dieses Thunderbolt auch mal außerhalb des Apple Universums zu benutzen gäbe.
Naja, lieber zaghaft ran wagen und dann funktioniert es auch.
Ja, weil ich hab jetzt gerade mal beim Thurman nachgeschaut, nach einiger Zeit und bin gerade ganz überrascht, es gibt irgendwie eine ganze Batterie von Thunderbolt Audio Interfaces, vor allem von Motu.
Ja ja, Motu hat da so eine neue Serie rausgebracht, so mit 8-Port rein, 8-Port raus und so ein Zeug. Allerdings Motu ist immer mit Treiber, das ist ein bisschen das Problem.
Ja gut, das sind bei den großen aber eigentlich alle, weil ihre Routing...
Also die Motu-Dinger sind ja auch nicht verkehrt, aber halt immer mit Treiber.
Ja, Motu has served me rather well, mit Einschränkungen. Aber das ist jetzt ganz interessant, also vor allem diese 828-Serie ist ja recht brauchbar. 777 Euro... Eine interessante Variante sein. Wenn ich erstmal meinen ganzen RME-Kram verkauft habe, dann kann ich mir das Geld auch leisten.
Ist immer noch so schlimm?
Das geht raus, weil nicht mehr. Diese kleine Summa 6 ist einfach so ein kleines Goldstück. Und ich hab jetzt einfach... Ich hab jetzt einfach keinen Bock mehr gehabt, so viel mit mir herumzuschleppen. Und ich muss demnächst auch nochmal ein bisschen mobiler sein. Und ich krieg halt jetzt ein Vier-Leute-Headset-Setup in einen Rucksack. Komplett.
Mit Soße und Schaf?
Mit auf jeden Fall einem, was ich brauch. Also mit allen Kopfhörern, mit allen Verlängerungskabeln, mit dem Aufnahmegerät. Ich steck das Teil einfach per USB an meinen R ran. Und bisher tut's halt super.
Und ab geht's in die Post.
Und kann halt mehr Kanalaufnahme machen bis zu vier Leuten. Und wenn ich tatsächlich in die Situation kommen soll, mehr als vier Leute zu haben, dann hab ich ja auch noch die Möglichkeit, zwei Mikroeingänge ohne Phantom-Power noch zu machen. Da müsste man sich noch mal überlegen, ob man dann noch mal so einen extra Verstärker, also noch mal so einen Einschleifer macht, dass man quasi die 48 Volt, so einen externen Speiseadapter für das Mikrofon nimmt, so mit Batterie. Das wäre dann so die Option. Dann könntest du halt bis zu sechs Kanäle machen. Das ist schon ganz schön shiny.
Was wollte ich sagen?
Shiny. Genau, ganz schön shiny, das wollte ich sagen.
The Shining. Nee, das war was anderes.
Es gibt sogar noch einen Zoom-Thunderbolt-Audio-Interface. Das TAK 2R.
Das hab ich dir doch gerade, das war das.
Nee, das war TAK 2.
Nee, ich hab TAK 2R gemeint.
Achso, du hast das TAK 2R gemeint. Das gibt's noch in so einer...
Das sieht auf jeden Fall nach schnuffiger, solider Hardware aus.
Ja, das kann man nicht abstreiten.
Das wurde auch mal zeitweise. Zoom war am Anfang doch ganz schön plastikmäßig unterwegs. Und das ist wirklich...
Also ich hab ja den Zoom H1 Stereo-Recorder. Das ist sozusagen das super billige Einsteigemodell für unter 99 Euro oder weniger. Und das benutze ich immer im Proberaum zum Band aufnehmen ad hoc, wenn ich nicht so viel Kram aufstellen will. Und ich bin auch immer wieder baff, was dieser kleine Mini-Plastbomber-Recorder für eine Qualität hinbekommt. Das haben die Zoom-Leute schon doch, muss man sagen, ganz gut im Griff. So kleine, handliche Set-ups bereitzustellen, die funktionieren und Sound liefern. So einen H1 kann ich auch empfehlen für die, die wirklich mal so ganz, ja, ganz basic mal einsteigen wollen mit Aufnehmen und gutem Klang.
Mal ein paar Tage später nachhören, ob es tatsächlich so gut war, wie man es in Erinnerung hat.
Hauptsache gleich ein H6, der kostet irgendwie 400 Euro und der ist einfach...
Ja, du, für manche Leute ist halt dann auch 400 Euro erstmal ein Batzen Geld, wenn man noch nicht weiß, ob man wirklich irgendwie sinnvoll irgendwas machen will. Und so 99 Euro kannst du halt schon mal eher verkraften. Um dann festzustellen, dass du dich das eigentlich überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Wenn dich das nicht interessiert, kannst du es eh wieder verkaufen. Dann kriegst du irgendwie den korrekten Preis dafür. Jeder wie er mag. Aber der H6 ist wirklich ein nettes Gerät.
Im Proberaum hier bei uns, da wird halt nicht groß mikrofoniert. Wir legen das Ding auf den Stuhl und haben dann halt einfach ein Belegexemplar von der Bandprobe sozusagen. Und die Qualität ist wirklich einfach so für einfachen Raum geschmissen. Ziemlich gut. Also auch dadurch, dass es auch Stereo ist. Und die Abbildung davon sehr gut funktioniert.
Kommen wir zu was vollkommen anderem.
Markus, du wolltest uns von deiner frühen Kindheit und deiner Mutter erzählen.
Worauf fährst du eigentlich deine Installation? Bist du mehr so aus dem Linux-Lager oder mehr aus dem BSD-Lager?
Linux.
Oder wer Java fährt, der hat in der Regel keinen BSD. Das ist nicht so zu Hause.
Hab ich mich, halt man nicht.
PKG install, Java, JDK und abgittet.
Hab da nicht irgendwie...
Also mein Minecraft-Server läuft ja auch auf ReversD und das ist ja auch Java.
Na gut, dann sag ich nichts dazu. Jetzt guck ich mal kurz, ob das Release draußen ist.
Man soll die Hoffnung nicht aufgeben.
Da stand 5. November, heute ist 5. November.
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie am 5. anfangen und am 10. wollen sie fertig sein. Ich weiß nicht, warum die 5 Tage für ein Release brauchen, aber...
Ja, aber hier steht Expected und dann gibt es daneben noch die Spalte Actual und wenn sie heute wirklich angefangen haben mit dem Release-Prozess... Und ich warte halt auf das 10.1, weil in dem 10.1 ein Buckfix ist, den ich unbedingt brauche. Ja, also wir reden von FreeBSD. Da gibt es jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so viel zu erzählen, außer dass Version 10.1 an Deporters ist. Totally unexciting.
Und 9.3 auch vor kurzem erst. Nein, ist ja schon länger draußen.
War das im Juli?
Was ist denn da so Neues im 10.1? Das ist immer ein bisschen schwierig herauszufinden.
Das ist das Wichtigste überhaupt für die unbedarften User da draußen, dass ZFS jetzt im Installer zu klicken geht.
Ja, aber das ging vorher schon.
Hast du nicht gefragt, was im 10.1 neu ist? Sorry. Na, wahrscheinlich keine 6 Falls mehr.
Hatt ich keine gehabt bis jetzt.
Ich leider so den einen oder anderen. Aber es war auch so eine Maschine im Vollausbau mit SATA-Controller und zwei Netzwerkkarten. Und wenn du dann einen IF-Stat oder einen IO-Stat gemacht hast und dann irgendwie die Liste der Devices aus dem Terminal-Buffer schon rausgescrollt ist, dann ist der mit einem Sack-Fault ausgegangen.
Habt ihr letztens in meinem Twitter gesehen von diesem schicken Bild?
Ja, habe ich gleich in meine FreeBSD-Toolbox übernommen. Oder geh mal auf github.com/huckel/, ich hab's auch in größer.
FreeBSD Performance Observability Tools.
Genau, da ist der Körner mit seinen ganzen Schichten bis zu den Applications erklärt. Und für jede Schicht hat er halt Tools, die einem da Debugging-Hilfe geben, wie F-Start, G-Start, D-Trace, Trust, Net-Start, Car-Trace, Sys-Control, Log-Start, VM-Start, TCP-Dump.
Timmer, Timmer, immer auf github.com/huckel/freebsd-toolbox. Da gibt's das erstens in groß. Und zweitens für die FreeBSD-Leute da draußen, vielleicht noch das eine. FreeBSD-toolbox. Da sammle ich gerade so, fange ich so an, so ein bisschen auch so Sachen zu sammeln. Da gibt's einmal das Bild in größer. Genau, Link da rein. Und dann gibt's bei oben noch so ein, kannst du glaube ich noch raufklicken, dann lädt er das glaube ich noch größer. Und dann gibt's dann noch so einen Commands-Markt da und wo ich auch nochmal so ganz viele nützliche Tools, gehen wir da, Commands, MD, genau. Und da habe ich auch nochmal hier so meine üblichen, oft verwendeten FreeBSD-Commandos quasi mal aufgelistet für die Leute, die vielleicht mal das eine oder andere... Und falls jemand Ergänzungen hat...
Ich habe hier bei Ports, eine Fetch und Update. Das kann man in einer Command schreiben.
Ja, geil, gleich hier Pull-Request. Du kennst dich doch jetzt aus hier mit dem... Let's do it, let's build an awesome FreeBSD-Commands und Toolbox und so weiter. Und ich habe auch da in dem Ding so ein Shell-Script, um einen FreeBSD-Root-ZFS-Boot fertig zu machen, falls man nicht den Installer und seinen Serviervorschlag für das File-System-Layout haben will. Kann man sich auch mal inspirieren. Gibt es auch schon tausendmal im Netz, das ist nichts Besonderes. Aber ich habe es, dachte mal, ich pack das mal alles jetzt so in einen GitHub-Repo, alles, was vielleicht mal nützlich sein könnte. Na ja, ist aber auch erst am Anfang. Aber dieses Bild, diese Infografik, die Dennis da postete, die ist auf jeden Fall auch nützlich dafür.
Ach, da geht einem auch das Herz auf.
Ich muss gestehen, aber dass ich dieses Bild auch nur bekommen habe, weil dieses scheiß Twitter manchmal doch ganz cool ist. Und zwar ich folge, glaube ich, den FreeBSD-Leuten nicht, aber irgendwie, weil ich oft halt auf einen anderen meiner Timeline der post retweetet immer die FreeBSD-Bugs, wenn sie mal wieder irgendwie ihr Heartbleed fixen und so weiter. Und weil ich da wahrscheinlich immer klicke, haben die gemerkt, alles klar, ich bin voll FreeBSD-interessiert und haben mir dann das Zeug hier vorgeworfen. Glaube ich jedenfalls. Und deswegen ist so ein Fras vorgeworfen.
Hier gibt es schon eine aktualisiertere Version, die gerade im Chat rumgeht.
IgMitool.
Mach dem Huckel mal gleich einen...
Gleich einen PR. Ja, sehr schön.
Warum ich überhaupt auf FreeBSD kam? Ein Hörer. Ich hab das leider natürlich mal wieder standesgemäß hinnahmlich parat. Aber war so nett, mir ein Buch aus meiner Amazon-Wunschliste zu klickshornen.
Das ist übrigens auch auf meiner Wunschliste, auch wenn die noch nicht existiert.
Aber ich glaube, ich muss das auch noch auf meiner Wunschliste tun.
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt sagen muss, es ist ein bisschen schade, dass es das nicht als EPUB gibt. Oder gibt es das als EPUB? Ah, 40 Days Free Access to Online Edition with Purchase of this Book Detail.
Ich kaufte das EPUB und du gibst nur das Hardcover.
Aber auf der Lastpitch ist doch alles...
Irgendwer war jemand...
Aber Safari Books, da kannst du das nur online lesen. Echt?
Irgendwer war auf diesem Meet BSDCA Kalifornien und hat sich das Buch auch von Kirk McCusick unterschreiben lassen, und ich war schon ein bisschen neidisch.
Ja, das hätte ich eigentlich ganz gerne als EPUB und ich verstehe nicht, warum es das nicht gibt, aber vielleicht gibt es das ja doch bei Safari irgendwie.
Aber sonntags haben wir das da gleich.
Okay, also wovon ist überhaupt die Rede und warum erwähne ich das?
Wie heißt das Buch?
Das Buch heißt The Design and Implementation of the FreeBSD Operating System mit der Betonung auf 2nd Edition. Und ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, von wann die 1st Edition war.
Das ist noch warm.
September kam die Edition raus.
Das riecht nach einer Motorsäge.
Genau, deshalb hat mir das schon mal da reingepackt.
Die 1. Edition ist 10 Jahre her, hat irgendeiner geschrieben in den Reviews. Mindestens.
Nee, das ist älter, das ist doch noch aus den 90ern. Wo steht denn das hier? Muss da hier irgendwo stehen. Naja, wie auch immer.
Wo ist denn der Lampada?
2. August 2004 steht hier.
Ernsthaft? Okay, ich hätte jetzt gedacht, dass es noch ein bisschen älter ist.
Das steht ja zumindest so bei Amazon.
Das kann auch sein, dass es nur nochmal ein Update bekommen hat.
Also hier steht, dass dieses erste Buch, eigentlich die 3. Edition of the successful design and implementation of 4.3, 4.4 BSD Operating System ist.
Und die sind von 1991 und 1996. Achso, ja genau. Es gibt im Prinzip drei Varianten. Es gibt die ursprüngliche auf das alte BSD, BSD 4.3 und später gab es dann mal eine Free BSD Version. Und davon gibt es jetzt die 2. Edition. Und die bezieht sich auf Free BSD 11. Das ist quasi das, was gerade so an der Development ist, noch gar nicht richtig release ist, oder?
Noch nicht, nee. Dauert auch noch eine Weile.
Also mit anderen Worten, das ist wirklich top aktuell. Warum ist das so interessant? Ich finde dieses Buch aus mehreren Gründen interessant. Erstens, ich kenne das nur, also bitte korrigiert mich. Ich will jetzt nichts Falsches behaupten, aber meines Wissens gibt es ein entsprechendes Buch nicht über Linux.
Kann ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so wirklich glauben.
Und auch nicht so in der Form, auch gar nicht über irgendein anderes Betriebssystem. Also es ist die Art von Buch, die ich über jedes Betriebssystem gerne hätte. Da steht nämlich einfach mal alles drin.
Die Wahrheit.
Die Wahrheit, genau.
Ich hab mir mal so was über Solaris geklickt. Das ist aber schwere Kost.
Ich hab da auch dieses von ihm singen, dieses US-10-Buch, oder? Das war da auch noch ziemlich deep.
Hast du es gelesen?
Ich hab es nicht gelesen. Ja, gelesen, also mehr als reingeblättert. Sagen wir mal so.
Ich glaube, das war so ein bisschen der Versuch. Aber der Unterschied ist schon noch so ein bisschen, das ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen der Blick eines Außenseiters, weil es halt ein Insider da nicht wirklich geben kann. Also, er mag da schon gute Einblicke gehabt haben, aber der erste Punkt ist, hier schreiben die Autoren des Kernels, Leute, die hier seit 20 Jahren im Unix-Development dabei sind, die schreiben dieses Buch. Insbesondere der McCusick ist halt so einer von den Vögeln, die halt wirklich Unix von Anfang an, also BSD von Anfang an mitentwickelt haben. Der saß da bei Berkeley und hat irgendwie an den Code geschraubt und dafür gesorgt, dass Unix frei wird.
Ja, er committet auch immer noch, und zwar das UFS ist ja so sein Kind, das ist so sein Ding.
Open Software Foundation, oder was?
UFS, das File System.
Ach, UFS.
Genau, das ist so sein Baby, was er pflegt.
Genau. Und das ist ein dickes Buch, das hat hier immer so locker 800, 900 Seiten. Und warum sollte man das lesen? Und wer sollte das lesen? Also mehrere Gründe, dieses Buch zu lesen. Erstens, allein schon der Anfang, die ersten 20 Seiten sind schon super interessant, weil da steht mal so die Geschichte von Unix drin. Das wird jetzt haarklein, bis auf den letzten Lawsuit, genau wer hat wann, wie wo was freigegeben.
Nur 20 Seiten, dann kannst du nicht die ganze Geschichte sagen.
Das ist eine sehr kleine Schrift, sehr vollständig. Der Titel sagt es auch schon so ein bisschen. Es ist halt Design and Implementation. Das ist jetzt nicht so ein Referenzmanual, wo man die ganzen System-Calls nachliest. Das ist keine Manual-Page oder so. Das ist kein Buch, was man jetzt nimmt, um dann damit Programme zu schreiben, wo man nachschlagen kann. Das ist so ein Design-Buch. Die komplette Inspiration, die sie gehabt haben, die ganzen Gründe, das steht hier drin. Sie schreiben, warum ist es so und wie ist es genau. Wie funktioniert unser Dateisystem? Wie ist es aufgebaut?
sind diese Datenstrukturen? Wie hängen die Blöcke zusammen? Was ist da mit was verbunden? Dasselbe natürlich dann auch mit dem ganzen Kernelservices, also Prozessmanagement, IOSystem, Memorymanagement. Alles ist hier im Einzelnen wiedergegeben. Security-Prinzipien, wie man Treiber schreibt, wie das Fallsystem im Detail und Firewall und der ganze Networking-Kram drin ist. Es ist halt jetzt hier auch ein ZFS-Kapitel drin. Das habe ich noch nicht gelesen. Das sind immerhin so 26 Seiten. Also wo halt mal auch genau erklärt wird, warum ZFS, wie ZFS etc. Auch ein paar ältere Sachen hier, NFS und natürlich auch System-Operation. Wie fährt man das Ding runter? Wie fährt man das wieder hoch?
Für die berühmten Have you tried turning it on and off again Momente?
Genau. Ich hab ähnliche Bücher schon gelesen und aus nichts hab ich so viel Verständnis für Betriebssysteme herausgezogen, wie einfach aus solchen Designbüchern.
Wie, du hast das erste durchgelesen?
Ich hab das BSD-Ding nicht ganz durchgelesen, aber ich hab seinerzeit den entsprechenden. Es gibt noch ein weiteres Buch, was sich mit Unix beschäftigt. Das heißt, glaube ich, der Klassiker Design of the Unix Operating System. Heißt das, glaube ich, noch mal nachschlagen. Das bezieht sich sozusagen auf das UR-Unix von Maurice Bach, gemeint als der Bach genannt, the Design of the Unix Operating System. Das ist eigentlich so der Klassiker, der ist von 86, also der ist auch noch älter als das BSD-Buch, aber der hat im Prinzip so die erste Art dieser Bücher, von der ich halt nur das von Bach kenne und eben die BSD-Bücher. Und das habe ich halt damals komplett mir reingezogen und da gingen bei mir einfach die Köre an. Also es war einfach, danach hatte ich einfach so ein untrügliches, selbstverständliches Verhältnis zu diesen Betriebssystemen. Ich kannte einfach jedes Design. Wenn da irgendwas, wenn da irgendwie die Festplatte gerappelt hat und der Pager wurde angeschmissen, dann wusste ich genau, was der Auslöser dafür war. Und ihr kennt das ja sicherlich auch noch diese Zeit mit den Festplatten. Ihr wisst schon damals, wenn so Leute zu einem kommen und sagen hier, ich hab hier ein Problem, mein Computer macht komische Sachen. Und dann wundern die sich, dass man halt als erstes Mal das Ohr aufs Gerät legt und sich anhört, was die Festplatte macht. Ich mein, das ist jetzt kein Witz.
Ich hab mein Ohr auf die Festplatte gelegt.
Man legt einfach das Ohr auf die Festplatte und man kann an diesem Grappel schon eine ganze Menge erkennen. Wird da gepaget, dreht da ein Prozess frei, ist da irgendwas kontinuierlich am Schreiben, klingt das normal oder klingt das nicht normal? All solche Sachen, wenn man das halt auch noch mit solchen Memory-Architekturen, Paging-Mechanismen etc. kombinieren kann in dem Moment, wo so ein Buch extrem hilft. Ich würd sagen, nach so einem Buch kommt nur noch Source Code lesen.
Also zwei Bücher, die auch, glaube ich, schon ähnlich gut sind, sind schon hier vom Tannenbaum oder Tarnenbaum. Modern Operating Systems ist das eine und das andere Computer-Architektur oder irgendwas in Deutschland. Nee, nee, hat auch eins über Computer.
Ich kenn nur das über die Netzwerke.
Warte mal, das Amazon, ich guck mal gerade hier, Tarnenbaum, Operating Systems, Computernetzwerk oder was? Wahrscheinlich war es dann doch Modern Operating Systems.
Ja, also der Tarnenbaum hat da auch extrem Klassiker geschaffen. Vor allem das Computernetworks ist glaube ich ganz wichtig.
Als ich im Studium zum entsprechenden Thema kurz vor der Klausur stand, kam irgendwie der Assi, der die Klausur gemacht hat, freudestrahlend an. Wir waren bei dem irgendwie in der Sprechstunde, meinte, eine neue Version vom Tarnenbaum ist erschienen. Und dann rannte er, sprang er durch sein Büro, hatte dieses Buch in der Hand und wir waren so, okay, alles klar, haben wir uns zu dritt dieses Buch gekauft, haben wir das gesamte Buch durchgearbeitet. Und dann war aber auch irgendwie die einzelne Prüfung nicht mehr so schwer. Es war völlig klar, was dran kommt.
Habt ihr also schwer ausgenutzt, dass der Mensch hier so ein Fan war?
Ja, also die Begeisterung war offensichtlich.
Also ich muss mal nochmal gucken, ob das wirklich dieses Buch mit dem Modern Operating Systems war, aber es war auf jeden Fall so ein Buch, wo da auch am Anfang so anfängt, so von Lochkarten und Tapes und warum man überhaupt so einen Scheduler brauchte und wie das überhaupt alles anfing mit den Single-User-Maschinen und wenn dann es zu lange gedauert hat, dass man einfach alles auf Lochkarten rausdampfen musste und wieder kommen musste, wenn man wieder einen Zeitslot hatte und wie so diese ganzen echten Zeitmanagement-Probleme, dann irgendjemand dachte, ja, Alter, wir machen jetzt einfach einen Scheduler, der dann das mal für eine Minute parkt und wir dann erst mal was anderes machen in der Zwischenzeit und wie dann das alles so komplexer und komplexer wurde und das waren 100 Seiten von irgendwie auch so, was weiß ich, 600, 700 Seiten, das war schon so eine Informationsdichte und so für Erkenntnisgewinn, Ich bin, das sucht man in manchen anderen Fachbüchern nach 300 oder 400 Seiten immer noch diese Erkenntnis.
Ja, also ich würde sagen, wer heute, also wer Lust hat einfach mal Unix als solches kennenzulernen und das ist eigentlich auch egal, wie gesagt, ich kenne nichts, kein vergleichbares Buch von aus dem Linux-Bereich. Der Vorteil von FreeBSD ist halt auch ein definiertes Release.
Es ist immer noch reine Lehre, sag's doch.
Genau, also es ist halt einfach...
Lehre mit zwei E.
FreeBSD 11 ist halt einfach mal genau das. Ich meine, nichts würde jetzt jemanden davon abhalten, ein entsprechendes Buch über den Lienungskernel zu schreiben. Vielleicht gibt es ja so ein Buch auch, ich weiß gar nicht, kennt da irgendetwas?
Ich denke schon, ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen.
Ich habe aber noch nie jemanden davon reden hören.
Das ist wahrscheinlich genau das gleiche, wie bei FreeBSD und Linux auch. Bei FreeBSD gibt es halt ein Buch, das ist es halt, so wie es einen FreeBSD-Release gibt. Das stimmt auch nicht ganz, inzwischen gibt es ja ein bisschen mehr, aber so mehr oder weniger. Und bei Linux gibt es wahrscheinlich ganz viele Bücher, aber welche jetzt so das richtig cool ist, hat sich wahrscheinlich nie so herauskristallisiert und dem steht ein bisschen was anderes drin. Und wahrscheinlich kann man das Linux-Thema auch nicht mit einem Buch erschlagen, weil es halt doch ein bisschen komplexer ist.
Was auch irgendwie cool ist, aber jetzt weiß ich leider aus dem Kopf nicht, wie das Buch heißt. Das muss ich nochmal nachgucken. Aber ein Kollege hat mir davon erzählt, dass es so ein Buch gibt, wo du quasi, was soll dieses First Principle-Konzept hat, also quasi erstmal alle Bausteine erklären und mit den Bausteinen dann was bauen. Und du baust dir im Prinzip mit dem Buch eine kleine Virtual Machine. Also du baust dir sozusagen einen Computer virtuell zusammen und baust auch die ganzen Bausteine von denen zusammen und schreibst auch deine eigene Bytecode-VM dafür, um dann am Ende dann mit Tetris zu spielen sozusagen. Und es geht aber wirklich so, er meinte das wäre wirklich richtig cool, so 600, 700 Seiten war das und er fängt halt wirklich an und du hast auch Aufgaben und musst dich da so ein bisschen durchfisseln. Und am Ende hast du dann so deinen Tetris programmiert von Null und Eins bis hoch White-Code. Und er meinte, das Niveau ist schon so, also Leute, die schon so ein bisschen programmiert haben, halt so ein, zwei Jahre, die sollten schon in der Lage sein, das Buch so nachzuvollziehen, weil er hat dabei die ganze Zeit auch viel erklärt. Also ist das Ziel schon nicht einfach nur so Puzzle-Aufgaben oder so mal ein bisschen Kopfmassage für sowieso die totalen Computer-Cracks, sondern eben so Lernen dabei. Aber jetzt habe ich blöderweise vergessen, wie es hieß. Aber ich versuche es mal während der Sendung noch rauszufinden und vielleicht kann jemand anderes jetzt was sagen in der Zwischenzeit.
Es werden jetzt so diverse O'Reilly-Linux-Bücher. Ja, System Programming, das ist halt nicht das, was ich meine. Understanding the Linux-Körner, keine Ahnung, klingt so ein bisschen mehr nach psychologischer Beratung. Ja, aber wo ist das Buch von Linus Torvalds? Also wo ist das Dokument von den Leuten?
Solange der Tauch-Software schreibt, wird es kein Buch von Linus Torvalds geben.
Tauch-Software? Hat der überhaupt schon mal ein Buch geschrieben? Kann der überhaupt Bücher schreiben?
Der kann nur coole Software schreiben. Und raten.
Also es ist alles so voll mit so totalen, mit so totalen Vollsympathen.
Ich finde ihn total sympathisch, den Linus. Ich hab einfach mir verschiedene Talks von dem angeguckt und was er so zum Beispiel zu Git alles so geschrieben hat und so weiter. Und der ist einfach flau, der weiß schon Bescheid. Und er ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so sozial kompatibel, sagen wir mal. Oder kann er sich jetzt... Aber das Ding ist halt, im Vergleich zu vielen anderen, hat er meistens recht, finde ich zumindest. Also das, was er sagt, auch wenn nur über die Form quasi, auch wenn es in der Form streitbar ist durchaus, hat er einfach schon einen Plan und erzählt keinen Stuss so.
Also diesen einen Talk, wo er Git vorstellt und dann über Subversion abrantet, bei Google, also der ist schon grenzwertig. Also er ist schon auch unterhaltsam, weil es macht halt Spaß, anderen Leuten beim Rant zuzuhören. Ich glaube, Freak Show-Hörer wissen, was ich meine. Aber es ist halt auch grenzwertig.
Ja, es gibt Rants und es gibt gute Rants.
Aber das Ding ist auch da, gerade bei dem hatte er Recht. Also ich meine, Google hat sich ja dann für Mercurial entschieden und hat dann irgendwie da ihr Friedhof der Open Source-Projekte aufgezogen und was machen sie am Ende, sind sie auch auf Git umgestiegen und was machen sie am Ende, gehen die ganzen Google-Code-Projekte jetzt auch auf Git ab. Also am Ende war sein Talk spot on.
Ja, aber Mercurial, Entschuldigung, das war so ein typisches Python-Ding, wo du irgendwie ein halbes Projekt kriegst, damit es richtig funktioniert, musst du irgendwie noch 25 Zusatzmodule installieren. Und bis das Teil irgendwie sinnvoll am Laufen hast, ist ein Tag vorbei. Also...
Ah, der Kollege hat mir das Buch genannt. Für alle, die basteln wollen, sozusagen ein bisschen forschen. Genau. The Elements of Computing Systems, Building a Modern Computer from First Principles. Der Link folgt sofort. Das hat er mir also wirklich wärmstens empfohlen für alle, die mal wieder den Kopf ein bisschen aufmachen wollen und mehr vom Computer verstehen wollen.
Das ist jetzt von Tannenbaum?
Nee, das ist ein Buch, was ein Kollege von mir gerade liest und mit programmiert. Das wäre wirklich sehr, sehr gut, um mal zu verstehen, wie alles so funktioniert eigentlich und was so eine CPU eigentlich so treibt. Und wie gesagt, du fängst halt an so mit... Genau, du fängst halt First Principles an und am Ende hast du ein Tetris selber programmiert sozusagen und die VM, in der dein Bytecode läuft, auch sozusagen, was ich gerade meinte. Aber es ist halt alles in so verdaubaren Happen. Also er meinte, für so ein paar Aufgaben muss man schon mal dann so einen Abend lang rumknobeln, aber es macht halt auch Spaß.
Ja, aber ehrlich gesagt, wenn man so die erste Alu mit Logikbausteinen selber zusammen gebastelt hat, dann versteht man auch wirklich, wie es funktioniert.
Ja, ja, wie gesagt, ich kann das jetzt ja auch erstmal nur so weiterreichen, ich hab's selber noch nicht gelesen, aber er schwärmte davon und es klang wirklich auch ganz gut.
Ja, ist ganz geil, weil die fangen mit burscher Logik an und dann so mit burscher Arithmetik und Gattern und so. So hab ich als kleiner Püx auch meine Computer auf Papier geschrieben.
Und es ist halt so dieses, also was heißt Konzept, aber so die Art Sachen zu erklären, finde ich halt auch immer gut sozusagen mit First Principles anzufangen. Also erst zu erklären, was sind so die ganzen Bausteine und dann erklärt man, was man damit machen kann und dann hat man immer so in dem Kopf so dieses ahhh, erlebensamt anfangen, denk mir so, äh ja, wozu braucht man das und dann, ja, und jetzt habt ihr das, das ist langweilig und das ist langweilig, aber wenn man das zusammensteckt, dann kommt da das raus und dann, ohhhh.
Genau, der Moment, wo du weißt, warum eine Zweier-Komplementzahl eine tolle Erfindung ist.
Ja, das muss man einmal durchgerechnet haben.
Und ganz schlimm finde ich halt zum Beispiel auch so bei Vorträgen, wenn dann die Leute irgendwie so Sachen erzählen und dann, ja, komme ich später noch mal dazu und dich erstmal mit irgendwelchen Fakten vollblasen, die erstmals gegeben anzunehmen sind, um dann später das dann noch mal aufzudröseln und das Pferd von hinten aufzuzäuben, wie man so schon sagt. Und da finde ich so den Lehransatz auf jeden Fall cooler.
Ja, das ist natürlich nichts für die Leute, die es nicht abwarten können.
Oder...
Die immer gleich wissen wollen, wofür brauche ich das denn, ein Logikgatter?
Ja, brauchen.
Aber...
Ich wurde gerade darauf hingewiesen, dass das FreeBSD-Buch auch im iBook-Store verfügbar ist.
Das FreeBSD-Buch ist auch woanders verfügbar.
Ich versuche es auch gerade hier im iBook-Store, aber der tut komische Dinge.
Da kommen wir auch gleich zu noch einem anderen Thema.
Hat einer einen Link auf das Buch, wo man mit Bitcoins bezahlen kann?
Moment, das Gute ist, dass dieses ganze Unix-Kapitel, von dem ich gesprochen habe, und auch das Design-Overview-Kapitel hier in dem Sample mit drin ist, wenn man sich das irgendwie runter... Das Design-Kapitel ist nicht komplett, aber das Unix-Kapitel ist auf jeden Fall schon mal komplett. Im Sample kann man sich also kostenlos im iBook-Store runterlöten.
Und bei Informit, da gibt es das Buch auch eben dann als Hip-Hop oder Mobi oder was auch immer oder eben dieses Bundle eBook und Buch oder als PDF. Und ich muss ja sagen, irgendwie diese ganzen Content-Vendor-Logins, die sind so scheiße. Ich habe so die Schnauze voll davon. Also gerade bei eBooks ist das so ein Pain.
Jetzt geht's los.
Kindl nie wieder. Das ist so ein Dreck. Schon allein, dass man die Apps natürlich nur in, also die Books, entweder nur auf dem Kindle lesen kann oder in dieser total behinderten Kindle-App. Ja, aber noch schlimmer eigentlich.
Weil sie weniger Geräte haben.
Ja, nee, also die App, ich weiß nicht, ob du die Kindle-App schon mal in deinem Leben gesehen hast. Das ist einfach eine Zumutung, da irgendwie durchzublättern, zu suchen oder, ich meine, du kannst ja nicht mal Text markieren und kopieren, pasten oder sowas. Du kannst es nicht drucken, du kannst nichts damit machen, außer das in dieser total kastrierten, eingeschränkten App zu gucken oder eben auf dem Kindle. Und dann geben sie sich teilweise halt auch null Mühe mit dem Layout oder so. Dann sieht das auch teilweise aus, wie hingekackt und hingeschissen.
Also ein Ex-Kollege von mir war ganz begeistert, wenn man tatsächlich nur Romane damit liest.
Also so Textwüste ist damit gut. Ja, also aber keine Ahnung, so ein Buch, wo man nichts rauskopieren kann, wo man nichts irgendwie drucken kann oder nichts mitmachen kann, außer in diesen Kasten anzugucken. Und dieses iBooks finde ich ehrlich gesagt jetzt auch nicht so viel besser. Also dieser Reader, dieser iBook-Reader für einen Desktop. Ich lese halt tatsächlich so technische Bücher auch öfters mal am Rechner und ich kriege da mit diesem iBooks auch die Krise.
Auch mit dem Desktop iBooks?
Ja, genau, das finde ich furchtbar. Das ist auch genau so ein komisches, wir machen jetzt eine App zum Lesen und ja, keine Ahnung, wie das Layout da die ganze Zeit rumfluschelt und man nur so beschränkte Optionen hat, wie man den Text jetzt präsentiert haben möchte. Und ich finde das ganz furchtbar. Also ich kaufe wirklich jetzt nur noch iBooks bei O'Reilly zum Beispiel, da kriegst du ja auch die in allen Formaten, also kriegst du einen EPUB, einen PDF oder was auch immer haben. Die sind glaube ich nicht mal gewatermarkt bei O'Reilly.
Weiß ich nicht, aber das geilste Feature bei O'Reilly ist, der Button alles in meine Dropbox bitte.
Ja, das stimmt.
Da lockst du dich ein, drückst den Button und dann wartest du fünf Minuten und dann hast du alle deine Bücher in deiner Dropbox drin. Und dann denkst du so, warum mache ich das nicht alle so?
Ich finde O'Reilly macht da in der Hinsicht eigentlich auch wirklich sehr viel richtig.
Ja, das ist furchtbar. Ich kaufe immer mehr Bücher, als ich lesen kann bei O'Reilly.
Hier und ich meine, ganz viele Verlage von diesen technischen Büchern zumindest, die haben auch ihren eigenen Store, wo man halt auch einfach DRM und Watermark-freie in allen Formaten die Books einfach haben kann. Und dann kann man sich die ja immer noch in seinen iBooks reinziehen hinterher. Aber so das zu kaufen bei so einem Drittanbieter, wo man auch, ja, weiß nicht, ich mag das überhaupt nicht, wo man dann da so eingesperrt ist und seinen Content nicht rauskriegt, für den man verdammt nochmal bezahlt hat.
Ja, aber ehrlich gesagt, da wiederholt sich ja die Geschichte, die wir bei der Musik schon hatten. Da haben dann irgendwie, dann zieht Microsoft diesen komischen Standard da auf und dann haben sie plötzlich keinen Bock mehr, schalten irgendwann ihre Lizenz-Server ab und den Leuten ist plötzlich die ganze Musik weg.
Also kaufe nicht beim Amazon, zumindest keine Bücher.
Ehrlich gesagt, bei Amazon, ich hab neulich bei Amazon wieder was bestellt und dachte, mich trifft der Schlag, weil die irgendwie über eine Woche gebraucht haben, um mir den Scheiß zu schicken. Dann dachte ich mir so, das ging doch mal irgendwann so innerhalb von einem Tag. Was ist denn damit passiert? Jetzt wollen sie irgendwie allen ihren komischen Prime aufdrücken und verzögern dafür dann aber künstlich alle normalen Sachen, die du kaufst. Also auf Amazon bin ich echt nicht mehr gut zu sprechen. Peak Amazon.
Peak Amazon, ja, sowieso, ich meine, die machen doch jetzt auch irgendwie die ganze Zeit Verlust und so, ne?
Schon immer.
Die haben noch nie Gewinn gemacht.
Doch, die machen immer so ein bisschen Gewinn. Doch, doch, ein ganz bisschen.
Rote Zahlen aller Orten.
Die haben immer nur ein bisschen Gewinn gemacht.
Also war nicht hier letztens diese Spiegelmeldung, dass irgendwie die Anleger jetzt ein bisschen unruhig werden, weil er irgendwie...
Ja, jetzt ist grad mal ein, zwei Quartale, aber ich mein, das ist absurd bei Amazon. Ich meine, die haben halt...
Waren das nicht mehrere Jahre?
Puh, schau nach. Ich kann dir die Quartel, die nochmals jetzt von Amazon ehrlich gesagt nicht runterbeten, soweit ich das in Erinnerung habe, ist das Ihr Prinzip, dass sie eigentlich immer nur sehr wenig Gewinn machen und einfach extrem viel investieren. Und sie setzen halt jetzt auch immer noch im Jahr 15, seit ihrer Gründung, auf Expansion. Und das machen sie ja auch super. Also man kann sie jetzt mögen oder nicht mögen, aber jetzt als Business Endeavor. Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch ging, als ihr das erste Mal Amazon gesehen habt.
Damals war das natürlich super, ja.
Ich meine, war nicht dein erster Gedanke auch so...
So hätt's schon immer sein sollen.
So hätt's schon immer sein müssen. Und sowas wie, das kriegen die Deutschen nie gebacken. Und sie werden alle sterben. Das war doch der erste Gedanke, den man aber hatte. Und genau so ist es auch gekommen. Zehn Jahre haben sie gebraucht, bis sie überhaupt verstanden haben, mit was sie das überhaupt zu tun haben. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt war Amazon schon so weit... Das hat, ehrlich gesagt, mein Hirn auch so latent expandiert, als sie dann irgendwie auf einmal anfingen, so mit S3 und solchen Diensten. Also überhaupt diese Idee, dass die ganze Technologie, die du dir aufbaust, um Bücherladen zu treiben, oder, sagen wir mal, überhaupt einen Einkaufsladen zu treiben, dass du dann auch noch selber Technologieanbieter wirst und das, was du dir ohnehin an Inhouse-Development machst, einfach auch noch mal als Produkt anbietest und mal so eben die komplette Technikszene der Welt hochgrößt. Ich meine, Amazon, das ist ein Unternehmen, das geht nicht weg. Das ist einfach so.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass sie alles richtig machen. Und alles Gutes.
Nö, heißt das alles nicht. Und ich finde auch irgendwie, ein neues Prime da mit Fernsehen gucken und teurer, können sie sich in den Hintern schieben.
Mit Anlauf.
Wer pingelt hier eigentlich immer?
Timmer.
Timmer pingelt.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist mein Telefon nicht stundengeschaltet. Wieso das denn nicht? Sowas passiert mir normalerweise nicht.
Also ich bin auf jeden Fall, hatte ich jetzt so bei den letzten E-Book-Einkäufen bei Kindl einfach mehr Frust als Lust sozusagen und werde jetzt nur noch auf dem freien Markt. Nee, auf jeden Fall direkt bei den Verlagen klicken, sofern möglich. Und hier prak prok, also die Pragmatic Programmers, die haben genau das gleiche. Ich glaube bei Manning haben sie es auch. Hier dieses...
Me-Up.
Na, dass man die Bücher bevor sie fertig sind schon lesen kann?
Achso, das kenn ich gar nicht.
Ja, das gibt es ja auch bei Riley.
Hier dieser Person Verlag oder Pearson, das früher, glaube ich, Edison Wesley war, wo es das Freebies, die Buch gibt, die haben ja auch ihren eigenen Store. Also die gibt ja keinen Grund da, sich stark künstlich einzuschregen.
Komischerweise kann man auf der deutschen Seite irgendwie nicht das Bundle aus Printbuch und E-Buch klicken. Das ist...
Echt, also man muss es leider immer noch sagen 2014 und Verlage, Musikindustrie und Filminustrie, sie haben das Internet immer noch nicht verstanden.
Übrigens, was ich auch ganz interessant finde, Bücher werden ja mit 7% Mehrwertsteuer versteuert und E-Books aber mit 19%, warum auch immer, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Luxusartikel.
Was fasst ihr dieses Hardcover-Buch an?
Das ist ja Grundlage.
Es geht ums Papier, nicht um das, was da drin steht.
Nee, nee, du musst das in den Kühlschrank tun, da ist das quasi Grundnahrungsmittel. Zu wissen, wie FreeBSD funktioniert, ist Grundnahrungsmittel. Deswegen nur 7%.
Herr Schubert, was ist denn dein Erinnerung dazu?
Hast du schon mal so ein Buch gelesen? Ich meine, bist du schon mal auf die Idee gekommen, so ein Buch zu lesen?
So ein Buch? Im Studium? Also diese Tannenbaum-Sachen und so?
Welche?
Na, diese Computernetzwerke, Computerarchitektur.
Was hast du studiert? Informatik? Hast du das zu Ende gemacht?
Einer der wenigen. Letztes Mal legst du nur Punto-User ein, heute ein Studien-Nichtabbrecher.
Studien vollender.
Du Studien vollender, du. So ganz normal Informatik auch?
Medieninformatik.
Medieninformatik, ist das dann welcher Uni gewesen?
HTW Dresden.
Also eine Fachhochschule. Das ist eh besser, oder?
Ich find's super, ja. Wir hatten alle Freiheit, wir konnten Projekte machen. Im Gegensatz zu den Allgemeinen Informatikern war unser Studium großartig. Ja, also...
Ich hab das nicht zu meckern.
Frauenanteil?
40%?
Mädcheninformatik.
Super.
Wurde auch Mathematik angeboten.
Ist das irgendwie an FHs anders?
Nein, bei den Allgemeinen Informatikern gab's 60 Leute. Und da waren 2-3 Frauen, wir waren 40 Leute, also die angefangen haben. Und ja, so größer 40% waren Frauen.
Das war ja früher auch mal anders. Früher waren ja irgendwie alle Programmierer waren Frauen.
Ja, und die Amis haben Turnhallen voll gesteckt mit Frauen, die die Flugbahnen für die Raketen berechnet haben.
Dass die Männer gemerkt haben, dass das ja doch ganz cool ist. Und dann irgendwie sind gleich wieder alle verscheucht. Alle verscheucht. Wo sind wir denn jetzt hier? Bücher, wir sind irgendwie so ein bisschen abgekommen.
Ja, The Book of PF über die...
Packetfilter.
Packetfilter, die Firewall von OpenBSD und FreeBSD. Da gab es auch ein Buch, was schon sehr, sehr, sehr lange auf ein Update gewartet hat. Und das gibt es jetzt auch bald in der 2. oder 3. Edition. Und das freut mich auch schon sehr, weil, wie gesagt, das Alte wirklich outdated war. Und es gibt sonst nicht so wahnsinnig viele gute Dokumentationen dazu. Genau.
Also bei FreeBest hier gibt es ja drei Packetfilter. PF, PFW und EPFW, ne? Kann sich die ja aussuchen. Und ich nehme aber auch schon seit langem PF. Und auf OSTenn ist, glaube ich, aber EPFW irgendwie am Start, ne? Das sind andere Firewalls. Bei EPF, wenn man ja so Regel 1000, Regel 2000, hast du so basicmäßig so eine Durchnummerierung. Und bei PF ist es halt ein bisschen anders. Es ist halt keine Zahlen mehr.
Ist cooler.
Weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, aber ja.
Naja, also zumindest haben die OpenBSD-Jungs das mal rausgetan. Und die FreeBSD-Jungs haben gemeint, okay, das brauchen wir auch. Und eigentlich kenne ich jetzt so nur PF-Nutzer. Also zumindest in unserem Nerd-Freundeskreis die BSD-User, die nehmen eigentlich, glaube ich, alle PF. Wir haben 100 Hacker gefragt. Welche Fakka benutzen Sie auf FreeBSD? 100 Hacker haben gesagt PF.
So, womit wollen wir denn jetzt hier mal unser Programm langsam zu Ende führen?
Na, das ist ja ganz klar.
Habt ihr übrigens die coole, von dieser coolen Lichtinstallation gehört, die jetzt hier in Belgien geht, die sich keiner angucken kann, weil die Züge nicht nach Berlin fahren?
Die steht bei mir schon vor dem Büro.
Der Zug? Ja, die stehen da schon. Leipziger Lindenstraße stehen die auch schon da unten.
Alle mit so einem kleinen Verhüterli oben drauf.
Genau, also wer das noch nicht weiß, es werden entlang des ehemaligen Mauerverlaufs in Berlin 8.000 Ballons insgesamt aufgestellt. Das sind so LED-Lampen. Einfacher Schuss. Da ist ein Ständer und oben kommt ein Luftballon rein, ein heliumgefüllter Luftballon, der von unten angeleuchtet wird. Ich hoffe mal und vermute mal, dass sie da gute Luftballons nehmen, also nicht so normale, weil die sollen ja wohl drei Tage rumstehen und am Ende losgeflogen werden. Dazu muss man eben richtige Luftballons haben.
Lass mich raten, die werden über ein Funksignal gleichzeitig ausgelöst?
Nö, ich glaube Leute sollen das selber machen. So sophisticated ist das gar nicht. Aber ich finde die Idee total gut. Und in dem Moment fällt mir übrigens ein, es gibt ja auch so richtige Luftballonläden, wer so Kindergeburtstage feiert und immer dieses Problem hat, wie Kinder wollen in die Luft steigende Luftballons haben, sind aber total frustriert, wenn derselbe Luftballon am nächsten Morgen schon wieder da niederliegt.
Ja, Helium ist ein fieses Zeug.
Ja, aber es gibt halt Luftballonläden, die halt so Luftballons haben, die von innen noch mal so mit irgendeiner, ich weiß gar nicht, was sie da reinmachen, so ein Gel oder so, also irgendwas kommt da noch mit, die sind irgendwie so noch mal extra beschichtet.
Ja, das Problem an Helium ist, dass es sehr schnell diffundiert. Also man sagt, wenn du Helium in eine Stahlflasche füllst, ist sie nach sechs Wochen leer, weil das Zeug durch Stahl durchdiffundiert. Du brauchst irgendwie so ein Polymer, so mit langkettigen, keine Ahnung, langkettigen Molekülen, die dicht genug gepackt sind, damit das Helium auch tatsächlich drin bleibt.
Weil Wasserstoff auch so was, ja, aber noch kleiner.
Nee, Wasserstoff ist größer, weil Wasserstoff nämlich Moleküle bildet. Wasserstoff hat gegenüber Helium, außer dass es brennbar ist, nur Vorteile, hat sogar ein Drittel mehr Auftrieb.
Naja, nicht so reaktionsfreudig auf jeden Fall ist Helium so.
Macht nur eine lustige Stimme.
Helium ist das Edelgas.
Da muss man schon richtig Druck ausüben, bis da mal was passiert. Naja, auf jeden Fall vermute ich oder hoffe ich mal, dass Sie daran gedacht haben. Ansonsten wird das irgendwie eine ganz nette Installation. Auch wenn es irgendwie keiner zu sehen kriegt, außer den Berlinern. Was irgendwie auch echt krass ist, dass jetzt irgendwie dieser fette Lokführerstreik ausgerechnet an diesem Wochenende stattfindet.
Naja, gut, es gibt vielleicht ja auch noch ein paar Leute, die mit dem Auto kommen.
Ja, genau, die bilden dann auf den Straßen auch die Staus von damals nach.
Die fährten Musse freuen sich.
Oh ja, das tun sie allerdings mit Preiserhöhungen. Ich hab auch mal nach Flügen geguckt, das sieht auch prekär.
Donner-Schock, Donner-Schock Ja, und es betrifft das hier gerade.
Wir wollten uns gerade an diesem Wochenende so ein bisschen zum Potlarf-Hacken treffen und jetzt müssen wir irgendwie alle aus der Ferne einfliegen lassen, weil es nicht anders geht.
Ja, Kleinbus-Mieten, aber wahrscheinlich sind auch die Mietautopreise in der Höhe.
Es ist alles enorm nach oben geschossen. Deswegen gab es noch die Sixx-Werbung.
Ich habe die Vermutung, dass die BSR, Lucky Strike und Sixx die gleiche Werbeagentur haben. Die BSR ist auch immer coole. Diese kleinen Bürgersteigstraßen-Feger, wo drauf steht Räumschiff, die sind einfach so süß. Das ist echt einfach so geil.
Das ist das Multitalent.
Die haben so einen krassen Imageboost, sich besorgend mit dem Wechsel zu dieser Agentur. Davor war einfach BSR maximal uncool und unsexy. Jetzt punkten die einfach so oft, indem sie den Leuten da sind, klatscht es schmunzeln auf die.
Es fing ja damit an, wo sie irgendwie diesen Müllmann hatten, der so ein bisschen als würde tanzen und dann stand das Saturday Night Feger drin. Und solche Dinge, es war echt der Hammer.
Ich finde die Müllarbeit, dem gibts mir, finde ich super.
Ja, das Räumschiff ist mein Favorit.
Vermannte Räumfahrt.
Mal sehen, ob es da ein Images-Google gibt.
Ja, ja, hier auf Flickr ohne Ende, fantastische Ideen.
Ja, genau, das ist es, dieser Feger, der sieht auch einfach so putzig aus. Ja, klickt mal da den Link da unten noch, im Chat.
Ja, vor allem, die haben auch wirklich so putzige Gräte.
Zippen ein, BSR, Werbung und Berlin, dann kommen sie alle.
Also putzig hab ich noch nicht gesehen auf so einem Teil.
Das würde ja auch ganz gut kommen. Oder Lola trennen.
Stimmt die Poliertesse gibt's noch.
Einmal für alle.
Es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie auch die öffentliche Meinung über die BSR mit dieser Werbekampagne auch wirklich nachhaltig bewegt wurde, oder? Also es geht doch jedem irgendwie immer so ein Schmunzel irgendwie über das Gesicht. Das ist echt krass.
Und übrigens, die BSR sucht Web-Developer, falls ihr euch jetzt auch schon ganz irgendwie...
Oder schon immer mal im Räumschiff arbeiten wolltet.
Die wollen da irgendwie, piffige Web-Developer haben auf ihrer Webseite unter Jobs irgendwie, hat mir letztens einer mal so zugeschickt. Ja, suchen die irgendwie Web-Developer für ihre tollen Web-Apps und so. Und finden den nächsten Find My Recycling-Hof und so. Falls jemand Jobs sucht, wieso nicht die coole BSR.
So, wer hat noch was?
Ach so, Roddy, ja, mach doch mal bitte.
Ein Tool, das nennt sich Bartender. Oder heißt es Mac-Bartender?
Hatten wir das nicht schon mal?
Damit kann man seine Menübar aufräumen. Der kann nämlich so eine Art zweites Menü aufmachen, wo man alle Menü-Items, die man nicht braucht, reinsortieren kann.
So Punkt-Punkt-Punkt-mäßig, damit das nicht immer alles zu sehen ist.
Das ist so großartig. Weil es gibt ja so viele dämliche Software, die nicht in der Lage ist, das Menü-Item, was sie da haben, auszuschalten. Manchmal will ich es einfach nicht sehen. Es gibt so viel Software, die man teilweise auch irgendwie haben muss, aus Peer-Pressure-Gründen, die dann so ein Ding da hat. Nenn ich es mal. Das räumt dann schön auf. Das finde ich schon sehr geil. Vor allen Dingen die Funktion, dass das Icon angezeigt wird, sobald es sich verändert. Du kannst ihm sagen, wenn sich das Icon verändert, dann packst du es wieder in die Hauptbar für zwei Minuten und dann verschwindet es wieder. Solche Sachen, das hat er wirklich gut gemacht. Ich hatte das jetzt im Test, bis die Test-Lizenz abgelaufen war und habe dann gleich zugeschlagen, weil ich kann nicht mehr ohne.
Das ist eigentlich für dich eine interessante Idee. Was lass denn? Du bist jetzt komplett im BSR-Werdespruch-Welt.
Feger und Sammler, das ist auch richtig gut.
Eine Übersicht?
Ja, na, hier Google, BSR-Werbung Berlin. Da haben sie schon mal wirklich schon mal über Trennung nachgedacht. Komm her, du alte Schachtel. Ach ja, genau, Corpus für alle Delikti. Auf so einem Mülleimer.
Mac-Bartender, genau, ich hatte auch noch irgendwie so ein bisschen was aus der Apps-Abteilung. Da muss ich euch noch mal nachschlagen. Da war noch was. Also übrigens, ich habe jetzt erst einmal Test-Flight ausprobiert.
Wow, du Teufelskerl.
Genau, also ich bin sozusagen jetzt mal Beta-Tester von jemandem geworden, der Test-Flight verwendet und das funktioniert gut. Also man kann dazu eigentlich gar nicht sagen. So wie man das möchte, es gibt eine neue Beta-Version, dann kriegt man schon eine Notification und dann installiert man dann darauf und pipa po. Und da ich auch wieder gemerkt, dass Apple da natürlich dieses Privileg hat, dass sie für bestimmte Apps URLs registrieren dürfen, so wie das ja auch mit YouTube, mit der YouTube-App zum Beispiel ist. Also wenn du halt im Safari-Browser eine YouTube-URL aufrufst, dann startet sich ja automatisch die App und das tut sich halt auf Basis dieser Art.
Ja, jede App kann ein URL-Händler registrieren.
Ist das so? Und dann, was passiert dann?
Die App gestartet und kriegt, hallo, hier hat jemand deinen URL-Händler aufgerufen.
Jede App darf das tun?
Ja, so zum Beispiel Bitcoin-Preise kommen so als URL, klickst du drauf, geht automatisch dein Bitcoin auf, zeigt den Preis und die Adresse schon, dann musst du nur OK sagen.
Ich dachte, das wäre... Ist nicht beschränkt?
Nee, nee, ja gut, ich weiß nicht. Du kannst wahrscheinlich keine üblichen überschreiben, aber wenn du dir einen eigenen ausdenkst?
Genau, dann gibt es hier noch... Hatten wir das letzte Mal schon den Horror aller Mathematiklehrer? Photomas.
Achso, das habe ich auch gesehen, habe ich mir auch angeguckt, aber das hat irgendwie nicht so richtig funktioniert bei mir.
Bei mir hat das funktioniert. Ich habe das mal auf irgendwelche Formel drauf gehalten. Also Photomas ist eine App, die benutzt die Kamera, scannt eine Formel und liefert dir dann sozusagen die Lösung dieser Formel. Das heißt, löst dann halt irgendwie was weiß ich, alles nach x auf, erklärt dir die einzelnen Schritte, etc. Also das ist sozusagen, das ist schon ein bisschen bedrohlich.
Ja, mir geht also ein bisschen der Sinn für das Ganze ab, aber... Warum?
Warum? Erkläre dich.
Ja, ich wüsste nicht, wofür ich das jetzt brauchen sollte. Aber vielleicht habe ich auch einfach nicht mit so vielen Formeln zu tun, bzw. wenn ich dann mal eine Formel habe, für die ich sowas bräuchte, dann wäre wahrscheinlich auch die App überfordert. Also nehme ich mal an, aber so für...
Ne, normalerweise, also man hat das nicht so oft. Andererseits sind ja auch Formeln etwas, mit dem man so aus dem Weg geht, weil man eben genau damit nicht so richtig umgehen kann. Also ich kann jetzt gerade das Beispiel nicht nennen, aber ich hatte tatsächlich...
Ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass ich mit Formeln nicht umgehen kann.
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich mit Formeln nicht umgehen kann, aber ich hatte halt mal... Ich weiß nicht mal ganz genau, was das Beispiel war, aber ich hatte mal so eine Anforderung und bin dann so ein bisschen dran verzweifelt. Und da hätte ich dann sowas gerne mal gemacht. Na ja, gut, ich sag nur, wenn man so in der Schule ist, ist das sicherlich so eine Abdehnung, die man sich mal anschauen möchte.
Ja, ich fand die knuffig, aber jetzt, wie gesagt, der Sinn hat sich mir nicht so ganz erschlossen.
Na ja, man kann halt Mathe dabei ganz gut lernen.
Ja, ich glaube, genau das lernst du dabei nicht, aber...
Warum?
Naja, weil du scannst und die Lösung kriegst. Ich meine, da ist jetzt irgendwie nicht so viel Lerneffekt dabei.
Wenn du es selber willst, dann kann es dir helfen. Und wenn du es selber nicht willst, dann hilft dir eh nix.
Ja, okay, aber das ist jetzt halt auch nix. Weißt du, die App macht es dir halt einfach, keinen Effort in das Problem einzubringen und dann lernst du da auch nix. Also wenn du das selber rausknobeln musst und da deine Fehler machst, dann bist du halt anders involviert, ne?
Ja, klar.
Wenn du nur der App beim Rechner zuguckst.
Ja, naja, gut, ich meine, mit derselben Argumentation könnte man ja auch Taschenrechner für vollkommen überflüssig beachten.
Ja, ich halte sie auch für vollkommen überflüssig.
Ich nicht, also wenn du jetzt irgendwelche siebenstelligen Zahlen miteinander dividieren musst, nimmst du dir dein Blatt Papier oder machst du es im Kopf?
Nimm er ja am Rechner, aber nicht am Taschenrechner.
Ich habe auch noch eine kleine App, die ganz witzig ist. Das ist so aus der Kategorie Musik, Witz und gute Idee. Im Paktor heißt das mit K geschrieben, The Drum Synthesizer. Ich habe die App jetzt noch nicht auf dem Gerät installiert, aber was das tut ist, du legst dein Gerät auf den Tisch und die Gyros registrieren, wenn du mit deinen Fingern auf den Tisch trommelst und machst ein paar sehr schöne Sound-Samples darüber. Du kannst wirklich dein Telefon auf den Tisch legen und mit deinen Fingern anfangen zu trommeln und das trackt erstaunlich gut. Ein Kollege hat mir das gezeigt.
Und dann spielst du das in dem Moment live?
Live-Vorführung, Jungs.
Du hast das nicht gekauft.
Ja, genau, ich hab's auf einem anderen Device und der Kollege hat es mir auch vorgeführt erst. Und jetzt dachte ich mir auch, ob ich es mir jetzt hier nochmal... Ich könnte jetzt auch mal klicken, aber es gibt, glaube ich, eine Demo, ein Video auf der Webseite, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, war das die App. Ja, eben, genau, ich war da auch erstmal voll. Beepstreet, Impactor, genau, es gibt auf jeden Fall YouTube-Videos, ah, hier Video-Demo, genau. Kannste mal, wenn du nach Impactor suchst oder beepstreet.com, Impactor, da gibt's ein Video dazu. Ja, ich würde mal die iPhone-Variante nehmen. Also ich hab's auf der Webseite, gab's das Video von denen. Warte, ich pack den Link mal in den Chat. Wo ist denn der Chat hier? Da ist der Chat. Ja, das ist auch schon ein Video-Demo.
Und jetzt buffzack.
Buffzack, boomzack return.
Das ist ja wohl cool, der tippt jetzt einfach auf seinem Tisch.
Und es kann auch Dynamik. Das ist einfach eine saukolle Idee. Wie machen sie das? Also es checkt auch, wie doll du drauf haust und so. Du kannst schon mit Dynamik spielen.
Und es funktioniert auch so gut wie da.
Warte mal, es heißt Driven by Audio Input. Also nicht der Gyro.
Echt?
Also vielleicht nehmen sie beides mit. Das weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, aber hier heißt es ja Audio Input. Also du musst den Kopfhörer anschließen und dann...
Ich habe nicht probiert, ob es funktioniert, wenn ich es in die Hand nehme und dann auf den Tisch haue. Ich habe es auf den Tisch gelegt, also kann sein, dass es auch wirklich nur mit Sound funktioniert, aber erstaunlich gutes Tracking. Also ich war wirklich baff, wie schnell das reagiert. Und genau, ich glaube, da ist auch ein kleiner Sequencer drin. Dann kannst du da halt voll abgehen, weißt du. Oder einfach nur ein Looper, hast einen Six-Track-Loop-Recorder, naja.
Schönes Spielzeug auf jeden Fall.
Genau, für die Leute, die mit so einem Zeug Spaß haben. Definitiv eine der lustigeren oder spannenden Spaßmachenderen Apps. Wie auch immer. So ein kleiner Tipp aus der, ich hätte noch so einen kleinen Tipp aus der Admin für größere Projekte-Welt. Und zwar habe ich, ja, also wenn man halt eine eine Webseite hat oder einen Blog oder so, dann muss man sich damit nicht beschäftigen. Aber wenn man mehrere so Domains hat und Projekte und so weiter und man will so Zertifikate für die sinnvoll managen, ja, also an einem Ort alles so in Übersicht haben und so weiter, hatte ich letztens bei VUGA das Problem und hab mal geguckt, was es so für Anbieter gibt. Diese CAs sind ja eigentlich alle scheiße. Aber DigiZert habe ich jetzt mal evaluiert und das war der erste Web-Service, wo alle Features drin waren, die ich erwartet habe, dass sie drin sind und darüber hinaus noch viel mehr. Und ich hatte so einen Call mit so einem Sales-Droid und das ist ja immer so dieses Sales-Droid-Call. Das wird halt auch von Facebook, IBM, Wikipedia, Intel, GitHub, alle benutzen das, die großen. Und die haben wirklich einfach ihr sogenanntes Enterprise-Managed-PKI, was eigentlich nur ein fancy-web-Interface ist, um deine Zertifikate zu managen. Das ist halt echt genau, was man haben will. Und das passiert mir so selten, dass ich mal Software oder ein Produkt sehe, wo alle Features, die ich mir so vorstelle, drin sind. Und dann kommt dieser Sales-Droid und sagt mir, ja, du kannst noch das machen, und du kannst noch das machen. Und ich sitze da, aha, das klingt echt praktisch und nützlich. Und die denken halt auch echt nach. Also du hast zum Beispiel, wenn du da deinen Account hast, gibt's auch so einen CSR-Generator. Und jetzt denkst du dir so, wie jetzt, Generatest du da die Signing-Requests auf der Webseite, dann machen die dir vielleicht noch den Private-Key oder so. Nee, du klickst da so einen schönen Wizard durch und klickst deine ganzen Optionen an. Und dann klickst du auf Generate und ich war so echt skeptisch, was passiert ist, wenn ich Generate klicke. Und dann kommt halt ein OpenSSL-Kommando, was du einfach sozusagen dann komplett in dein Terminal pastest, mit allen Fields auch schon vorausgefüllt ist, heißt du kommst nicht in dieser, gib mal dein Country ein und so weiter. Also die haben echt bei allem mitgedacht, voll gut. Sie lassen sich das halt natürlich mit etwas kostspieligeren Zertifikaten wiederum bezahlen. Aber wenn man halt eine größere Firma hat oder irgendwie eine Firma mit mehreren Domains und so weiter, sagst du doch, wenn es die Firma eh zahlt. Ja, also echt, das ist es aber auch voll wert. Die haben auch 24 Stunden Chat-Support und das haben viele, ja, so sagen hier Klick und Chat und dann steht dann, wenn du zu deutschen Bürozeiten da ankommst und in Amerika schlafen sie noch, ja, dann kriegst du da auch keinen im Chat und bei denen ist es so, klickst du drauf, kriegst du sofort irgendwie einen Typen. Und die haben coole Features zum Beispiel, du kannst ein Wildcard-Zertifikat machen und manchmal hast du zum Beispiel einen CDN benutzt und du willst deine Domain bei dem CDN hosten und du willst auch HTTPS unterstützen, heißt das ja, du musst deinen Zert in dein Private Key denen geben, was natürlich nicht so eine coole Idee ist. Was du bei denen machen kannst, du kannst zum Beispiel deine Zertifikate kostenlos duplizieren und kannst neue Private Key Pairs sozusagen generieren. Das heißt, du könntest jetzt deinem CDN ein eigenes Private Key Pair da auch generieren und so und diese ganzen extra Features, die sind dann wiederum kostenlos, also die Anschaffungskosten sind sozusagen ein bisschen höher als zum Beispiel bei Start SSL, wo es kostenlos Zertifikate gibt. Also die sind schon eher so für, weißt schon, du hast irgendwie viele Hosts, viele Domains und du musst das managen. Also bei uns ist halt das Problem gewesen, jedes Team hat sich selber Zertifikate gekauft, die haben Rapid SSL, GoDaddy, Hodgepodge SSL 2000 und so und niemand wusste, wie viele Zertifikate wir eigentlich haben, wann die ablaufen, welche Schar 1 sind, welche Schar 2 sind. Es gab nichts. Also in so einer Firma kann das halt dann schon schnell der Tod sein. Schnell der Tod sein und deswegen stellen wir das jetzt halt mal alles um und so von eben deswegen, es ist halt für eine bestimmte Kategorie von Problemen nur überhaupt sinnvoll, aber wie gesagt, für eine einzelne Webseite musst du nicht zu Digizert gehen, aber falls ihr in einer Firma irgendwie arbeitet und ihr habt so ähnliche Probleme, dann kann ich das durchaus empfehlen. Die haben echt nachgedacht und einen coolen Service und so.
Gibt es denn zur Stadt SSL irgendwie noch eine Alternative, wo man sich mal so...
Na ja, wenn du halt einfach nichts erwartest, so außer ein Zertifikat.
Ich erwarte eine Webseite, die, wenn ich sie das zweite Mal besuche, mir das Gefühl gibt, ich weiß, wo ich draufklicken muss. Das ist bei Stadt SSL definitiv nicht das Gefühl.
Was meinst du denn beim ersten Mal?
Nee, auch nicht. Aber wenn du es einmal durch hast, dann müsste man ja meinen, jetzt hat man es gelernt, aber das ist einfach nicht...
Also zum Beispiel, ich weiß nicht, wie es jetzt aktuell bei Rapid SSL ist, aber zum Beispiel war es da so, du kaufst ein Zertifikat und dann willst du dich da einloggen und nochmal irgendwas ändern oder umkonfigurieren und so und du hast da halt keinen Account. Also du kriegst dein Zertifikat per E-Mail und dann war es das halt. Und wenn du nochmal ein Zertifikat oder das neu ausstellen willst, dann musst du halt dich nochmal da durch den Prozess klicken und nochmal 49 Dollar bezahlen zum Beispiel. Also sowas früher, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht haben sie das geändert. Zum Beispiel bei DigiZ oder auch bei den anderen größeren CAs, das ist halt so, du kannst einfach so lange das Zertifikat valide ist, kannst du das jederzeit neu generieren und auch mit anderen Features und so weiter und so fort. Und das gibt es dann halt also diese ganzen Sachen, glaube ich, bei diesen billigen Dinger nicht.
Ich habe letztens bei GoDaddy halt meine Zertifikate neu gemacht, weil die noch Schaar 1 waren, dann bin ich bei GoDaddy hin und dann gab es auch so einen Prozess, um Schaar 2 draussen zu machen. Hat nichts gekostet, die hatten das alte CSR noch da, haben das einfach alles neu gemacht.
GoDaddy hat halt einfach in der Vergangenheit so ein paar Mal amtlich so verkackt, deswegen haben die bei mir so einen schlechten Ruf eigentlich, aber ja.
Die hatten auch welche Domains gesperrt oder so wegen.
Ja, die waren einfach echt uncool, ja. Die haben ihr Kammerkonto komplett geleert quasi.
Werden als Frosche wieder geboren.
Als Kröte ohne Schild. Als nackt mulch. Oder wie ist dieses hässliche Tierchen? Nackt mulch, genau so was. Naja, auf jeden Fall fand ich das mal ganz positiv, meinen Service zu finden, der nachgedacht hat und Features hat, die man haben will tatsächlich. Es gibt ja ganz viele Gegenbeispiele.
Der nackt mulch ist übrigens das einzige staatenbildende Säugetiere, das es gibt.
Staaten?
Staaten bildend, ja.
Was ist mit Menschen jetzt?
Naja, die sind nicht in dem, also ich meine, so ein Bienenstaat und die Bundesrepublik Deutschland sind schon zwei unterschiedliche Dinge.
Und habt ihr gelesen auf dem Spiegeldee, dass sich diese...
Gibt's da Internet im Bienen-Haus?
Im Bienenstock?
Ja, Wifi gibt's da auch, du. Das ist wie in Deutschland. Nee, Wifi gibt's im Bienenstock auch, wenn da ein AP daneben steht. Aber...
Wir sind aber nicht alle aus Eiern geschlüpft, die die Merkel gelegt hat, also insofern.
Aber habt ihr heute auch auf Spiegel gelesen, dass sich in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern südamerikanische Vögel, Großvögel, so Straußeneinig, wie heißen die? Nandus? Die sind vor 15 Jahren aus einer Zucht ausgebrochen und vermehren sich und es gibt 100 frei lebende Nandus in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und sie vergrößern ihr Revier und sie richten aber keinen Schaden und fressen eh nur so Gras auf der Wiese und so. Du kannst also in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern so einen kleinen Waldspaziergang machen und dir so einen zweibeinigen Riesenvogel vor die Nase laufen lassen.
Ich nehme mal an, dass die Wölfe, die aus Polen zuwandern, das Problem schon irgendwie in den Griff kriegen.
Naja, also bisher vergrößert sich es. Und sie haben auch die milden Winter prächtig wohl überstanden.
Da wandern schon die Vögel aus Amerika aus. So weit ist es schon gekommen.
Ja, näh, mehr Nandos in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern als Internetzugänge.
Ja, da hier kannst du nochmal klicken, für die, die es gerne mal live erleben wollen. Da sieht man auch nochmal diese...
An so einem Nandu kann man doch bestimmt einen USB-Stick ranhängen. Schmecken die? Und dann passt auch Datenverkehr.
Deswegen werden die, glaube ich, gezüchtet.
Ach, Südamerika, sieh an, nicht Nordamerika.
Ich glaube, deswegen werden die gezüchtet. Vor allen Dingen zum Verspeisen.
Echt?
Ich glaube ja, also sonst...
Gibt es dann demnächst so einen Nandu-Burger in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern?
Der Mecklenburger mit Nandu-Fleisch.
Das ist auf jeden Fall aus der Kategorie miscellaneous. Falls die Hörer das noch nicht bemerkt haben sollten.
Da geht ja auch der Tweet von Axel Springer irgendwie noch ganz gut rein, ne?
Nämlich, welcher war das?
Naja, sie haben noch jetzt irgendwie auch so richtig klein beigegeben zum Thema Lassungsschutzrecht.
Ach Gott, so peinlich.
Ja, so peinlich. Aber ich fand diesen Tweet sehr bemerkenswert. Wo ist er? Sie haben ihn mal Zahlen genannt. Das fand ich bemerkenswert. Also, wer den Schuss noch nicht gehört hat.
Den hat's getroffen.
Lassungsschutzrecht geht genauso nach hinten los, wie das alle vorher gesagt haben. Und heute hat irgendwie Axel Springer, mein Gott, wieso finde ich jetzt diesen scheiß Tweet nicht. Ich finde es jetzt natürlich wieder nicht. Schade. Auf jeden Fall haben sie Zahlen gepostet, wie groß die Einbrüche sind, dadurch dass ihre News Artikel von Bild und Welt und was war noch, was sie nicht freigegeben hatten, es waren 4 Sides.
Da kommt sie im Chat.
Suchtreffig bricht um 40% ein, Google News Treffig umfasst 80%.
Wir wissen nun sehr präzise, wie Google jeden bestraft.
Wegen massiver Folgen der Diskriminierung.
Sie haben so einen Knall, das gibt es gar nicht.
Um es mit Pfeife zu sagen, damit konnte ja keiner rechnen.
Das ist so ein Scheiß.
Döfner wissen nun sehr präzise, wie Google jeden bestraft, der ein Recht wahrnimmt, dass der Deutsche Bundestag ihm eingeräumt hat. Also das ist auch wirklich...
Ich glaube, Sie wissen jetzt, wer präzise, wie Google auf Geschäftsanfragen nicht eingeht, von denen Sie keinen Vorteil haben.
Das ist wirklich eine interessante Formulierung. Also ein Recht wahrnehmen heißt, Google zwingen zu wollen, ihnen Geld zu geben für etwas, was Google gar nicht haben will.
Und was ihnen eigentlich nützt. Oh man, echt, also wie ich vorhin schon sagte, Verlage, Musikindustrie und Filminustrie, die haben das mit dem Internet noch immer nicht verstanden.
Ich kann dir den Hintergrund erklären.
Es geht um das Leistungsschutzrecht. Davon wirst du ja sicherlich schon mal von gehört haben. Das war ja im letzten Jahr eine ausführliche Debatte noch vor der Bundestagswahl. Und dann haben sie irgendwie die CDU und am Ende auch die SPD soweit bekommen, sich für dieses Leistungsschutzrecht einzusetzen. Leistungsschutzrecht ist eigentlich der falsche Name. Es ist ja eigentlich mehr ein Leistungsschutzgeld. Es ist sozusagen der Versuch, Suchmaschinen dazu zu bringen, dafür Geld zu bezahlen, dass sie die Artikel auch zitieren, auf die sie verlinken, auf ihren Suchportalen, die die Leute aber dann überhaupt erst dahin bringen, wo die Verlage dann Geld machen. Also ich weiß immer noch nicht, ob das so der beste Vergleich ist, aber Siegsoß hat ja mal diesen schönen Vergleich mit dem Taxifahrer gehabt, das ist sozusagen so, du möchtest auch noch Geld von dem Taxifahrer haben, der die Kunden dir zu deinem Laden fährt, ja?
Ne, anders. Du möchtest Geld von dem Taxifahrer haben, der dir die Broschüre dem Fahrgast in die Hand drückt, was für ein tolles Hotel es doch wäre, zu dem er dich hinfahren könnte. Und dafür, dass er die Broschüre, ne?
Ja, so kann man es auch definieren. Also die Vergleiche hinken alle so ein bisschen, aber Tatsache ist, sie wollten einfach dafür Geld sehen, dass ja Google ihre Ware so sehr in Anspruch nimmt, dass sie sie sogar zitieren. Das ist vollkommen hanebüchen. Und am Ende ist das ja durch das Ganze hin und her so aufgeweicht, dass eben klar war, dass, wenn du nur den Titel eines Artikels zitierst, auf gar keinen Fall zu zahlen hast. Und wenn du eben mehr zitieren möchtest, wie zum Beispiel ein Foto, was da drin erscheint, oder eben so ein Exzerpt, naja, dann müsstest du dir halt eine Lizenz besorgen. Und die meisten Verlage haben halt gesagt, geht's noch? Und hier, bitte Google, macht einfach mal kostenlos weiter. Aber Springer und andere Verlage, die sich halt, vor allem dieser unsäglichen Fondue Media engagiert haben, die haben sich halt auf die Hinterbeine gestellt. Und irgendwie versucht, beim Kartellamt da irgendwie eine Klage zu erwirken, die Google irgendwie dazu zwingt, dann ihnen ihre Produkte abzukaufen. Das war so hanebüchen, dass sogar das Kartellamt das einfach abgelehnt hat, sich damit überhaupt zu beschäftigen. Und so nach dem Motto, also erst mal wissen wir nicht, wovon ihr redet, zweitens kommt mal klar und drittens, wenn ihr so weitermacht, dann müssen wir uns wohl mal euch anschauen, ob ihr nicht vielleicht ein Kartell darstellt. Weil so wie ihr euch hier gerade benehmt, geht es nun irgendwie auch nicht. Das war also das größtmögliche Eigentor, was man sich da überhaupt einfahren konnte. Und der Gipfel war dann, da hat Google halt angekündigt, naja, also wenn das so ist, dann halten wir uns doch einfach an das Gesetz. Und dann nehmen wir halt eure kostenpflichtigen Sachen raus und der Link bleibt. Wir linken da gerne noch mit dem Titel drauf, aber dann ist es halt nicht so am erster Stelle. Mit dem Ergebnis, wie wir jetzt hier irgendwie sehen, so 80% Treffikeinbruch. Das bezielt sich übrigens jetzt nur auf eben diese vier Webseiten, haben wir sie zuerst schon alle genannt, also Welt, Computerbild, Sportbild und Autobild. Ich dachte die waren, achja, ne doch genau. Und weil nämlich für die vier hatten sie noch eine Aus-, also für die vier hatten sie quasi keine Erlaubnis angeboten. Vorher haben ja alle in der VG Media vertretenen Verlage Google eine sogenannte Gratis-Einwilligung, eine widerrufliche Gratis-Einwilligung. Dass sie das dann halt doch machen durften, also sehr ehrbar von ihnen. Nur springen aber dann halt der Meinung, naja aber jetzt nicht Welt und Computerbeiratung, so ihre großen Cash-Kraus, damit wollten sie sozusagen, ich weiß nicht was sie wollten, irgendwie haben sie wahrscheinlich immer noch geglaubt, dass Google dann im Kreis springt. Oh Gott, wir dürfen nicht mehr auf sie linken. Ich weiß nicht, ob die da einfach nur das falsche Kraut rauchen.
Ich glaube die rauchen kein Kraut, das ist das Problem.
Ja, aber vielleicht, weiß es ja nicht, vielleicht haben die ja so einen Schamanen da in der Vorstandsetage, der die ganze Zeit irgendwie so Gerüchen hält.
Ich glaube das Wort, nach dem du suchst, ist Filterbubble. Die leben, also das ist keine Bubble, das ist glaube ich schon so eine Marmorkugel. Also da dringt auch nichts mehr rein, die merken einfach gar nichts mehr.
Ich habe das Gefühl, die haben alle eine Plastiktüte auf dem Kopf. Weil auch so mit der Frischluftzufuhr und so, das ist definitiv alles schon im Grenzwert.
Wer weiß, ob da eine Klimaanlage ist im Axel-Springer-Tower.
Wir wollen es nicht wissen. Auf jeden Fall, jetzt haben sie halt irgendwie auch klein beigegeben. Ich meine, es wird einfach mal gar nichts rauskommen. Der nächste Knaller war, dass irgendwann noch der Meinung war, naja, also unsere Klage, also ich weiß nicht, war das eine Klage, Klageversuch, Einwand, auf jeden Fall das, was sie da beim Kartellamt vorgebracht haben, was halt so grandios gescheitert ist. Dann kam sie dann so gleich mit, ah, unser Ding ist nicht durchgekommen beim Kartellamt. Da muss ja wohl beim Kartellgesetz was falsch sein. Vielleicht müsste man das mal ändern. Also die sind auch wirklich gnadenlos und ja, auch SPD, dann hier irgendwie Sigmar Gabriel sind auch gleich drauf eingestiegen und so, naja, das müsste man sich ja vielleicht mal anschauen und so. Ich weiß nicht, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie mit so einer kurzen Reaktionszeit da überhaupt groß darüber nachgedacht haben, dass es einfach Springer hüpft, ja.
Und der Gabriel springt.
Und der Gabriel springt und der Rest wahrscheinlich genauso, das ist einfach so.
Einfach den Recht zu geben, ja, das müsste man sich mal anschauen, das kostet die Politiker ja auch nicht.
Zumindest nicht erstmal nein sagen oder so, sondern erstmal nur sagen so, ja, das kann man ja mal prüfen. Prüfen heißt so viel wie, ja, ich hab jetzt gerade...
Rufen sie uns nicht an, wir melden uns.
Ich hab jetzt gerade keine Zeit irgendwie so schon komplett in den Atos einzusteigen. Ja, wir tun zumindest mal so, als wären wir da grundsätzlich zu breit. Ach, Gottchen, also das ist wirklich...
Ja, aber schade ist, dass sie jetzt diese gratis Lizenz erzeihen, dass Google wieder einschaltet, ne? Weil ich meine, das wäre ja ein Segen für die Menschheit, wenn da keiner hingelenkt wird, weil das ist ja schlimm.
Ja gut, der Schaden ist natürlich jetzt trotzdem angerichtet, weil das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, eine Lizenz, die sie Google eingeräumt haben. Und damit haben wir genau das, dass es genau das passiert, was sie angeblicher verhindern wollten, nämlich jetzt wird der Monopolist gespergt. Also Google darf das.
Die anderen nicht.
Aber alle anderen, wenn die jetzt bei der VG Media angetrapt kommen und sagen, wir wollen aber auch, dann sagen die, ihr seid ja nicht wichtig.
Aber dann ist der nächste Stopp ja wieder das Kartellamt.
Nein, nein, wieso? Wenn du jetzt eine Suchmaschine, wenn du so ein Start-up machen willst.
Wenn ich jetzt DuckDuckGo hätte.
Na, sag mal mal, du möchtest so ein cooles Newsportal. Du willst Freak News machen und willst auf coole Freak News irgendwie linken.
Zum Beispiel auf Lepers in Oldenburg. Neue Kollektionen.
Skandal hier irgendwie. Logo Missbrauch in Oldenburg. So, und dann willst du natürlich auch das Foto in deinem Snippet drin haben. Ja, und dann kommt irgendwie der Ratzelburger Kleinanzeiger und sagt 100.000 Euro, weil ihr habt ja hier irgendwie ein 12x12 Pixel Thumbnail von unserer Webseite benutzt und behauptet. Und habt ihr keine Ehre?
Wollt ihr hoch?
Wohin?
Runter meinste?
Nein, hoch.
Was denn?
Die Leite hoch.
Diese?
Den Viewport runter.
Das ist vielleicht der erfolgreichste Misserfolg, den wir je hatten.
Was?
Sagt Döpfner.
Der erfolgreichste Misserfolg?
Ja, ich hab's auch nicht verstanden, aber ich fand's einen schönen Satz.
Ganz unten. Der letzte Satz in der Matrik. Das Leistungsschutzrecht für die Verlage letztlich keinen großen Wert hat, räumt man mittlerweile auch in den Reihen von Axel Springer ein, so erklärt Verlagschef Martin Matthias Söbner.
Der erfolgreichste Misserfolg. Ich würde ja eher vom floppigsten Erfolg reden.
Der erfolgreichste Flop. Flop 10, erster Platz.
Die größte Face Palm.
Das ist das Gegenteil von erfolgreich.
Na misserfolgreich.
Der erfolgloseste Erfolg.
Ich sag's doch, Flop 10, erster Platz.
Gibt's auch ein Bild von diesem Döpfner?
Klar.
Leistungsschutzrecht.
Also wirklich.
Ja.
Nee, ich glaub, dass die Mountain View-Jungs, die haben wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal gelacht, die haben irgendwie nur den Kopf geschüttelt und sind aus dem Meeting.
Ja, die Deutschen wieder halt, erst vergausten sie ihre Bilder auf Street View von ihren Häusern und jetzt... Weiß man eigentlich, ob andere Länder auch so hier, ich will mein Haus blirren, irgendwie? Glaubst du, das ist auch ein anderer?
Nein, das macht nur Deutschland. Ja, die Deutschen haben im Internet wirklich einen schlechten Ruf und den auch absolut zurecht. Es ist wirklich schlecht.
Joa, da haben wir es doch jetzt bestimmt zu langsam, oder? Ist ja Mitternacht jetzt hier.
Wir fahren jetzt runter, ich glaube uns fällt jetzt nicht mehr sehr viel ein.
Ja, vor allen Dingen.
Oder?
Das kann man alles schieben.
Ja, der Rest wird alles geschoben und wird irgendwie verschoben. Jetzt ist ja auch schon Mitternacht. Da geht nichts mehr hier bei uns.
Kommt alles mit ins nächste Release.
So, Dank an Markus. Fürs Erscheinen und Berichterstatten. Viel Spaß und Erfolg mit der Schlüsseljagd und ähnlichen Geschichten.
Danke.
Und wir werden dann hier in zwei Wochen, wie gewohnt, wieder aufschlagen. Dann wird uns wahrscheinlich Clemens Bericht erstatten, wie es so jetzt in Hawaii.
Der wird rumjammern, dass es nur geregnet hat in Hawaii.
Und der auch überhaupt nicht rausgekommen ist aus seinem Zimmer. Das hätte er ja auch in Frankfurt haben können. Ja, Hetze.
Hetze, Hetze. Fahrradketze. Ne.
So, bevor die schlechten Witze hier total überhand nehmen, spielen wir hier mal so ein bisschen Abschlusstound ein, oder?
So machen wir das.
Ja, schaltet in zwei Wochen wieder ein und ladet fleißig runter und klickt fleißig Flatter-Buttons, denn dann hilft uns weiter. Ansonsten die Ohren steif, gute Laune und Reise vorbei.